welcome back everybody for the feed a online
world corporate chess championship when all is
said and done there will only be one i am joined
by anna kremling anna great to have you today are
you excited for the finals i'm super excited for
the finals i mean this seems to be the best day to
join this commentary so it's an honor once again
to do commentary with you robert it's been a while
but i always really enjoy doing it same here and
it's going to be a fun event because there are
only eight teams remaining and those eight teams
are vying for a world championship title let's
remind everybody of the new format because
we're out of the group stage so we get here
there will only be one team winning this event
so for the pairing purposes the teams were ranked
one through eight according to their average team
rating the quarter and semi-finals will just have
one match like we've seen before the finals will
be a dual match two matches you play your four
games you get a little rest you go back for four
more and if there is a tie the tie is broken with
a blitz game three minutes two second increment
and if the blitz match is drawn there will be
an armageddon game so can you believe that
not only is there a team competition anna
but there could also be blitz in armageddon
what kind of pressure does that put them under
armageddon always puts a lot of pressure um it's
really difficult to know if you would rather play
white or black that's sort of like a preference
but armageddon basically means playing a game
that's gonna be full of pressure and doing that
in a team that just adds more pressure because
all of a sudden your result doesn't just affect
yourself but it also affects the whole team so
that would definitely be something very exciting
absolutely let's tell everybody who these eight
teams are we have the bracket you can see their
rankings by average team rating they all won their
groups you see spare in the top left taking on erg
spare bank trade union taking on empty solutions
in the 4-5 match up morgan stanley hungary taking
on pt pelo buhan tanjuk priyak and gronke bank
taking on anahuak there in the bottom right and as
the games get underway let's look at the matchups
just a broad overview here of the teams and
their players there are grand masters including
super gm yon napomnishi up there for spare you
have uh york meyer for gronkey bank but let's go
to the games let's move on to the games there
um as they are beginning so let's start with
none another then jan upon shiana has the black
pieces against anuar is a grand master playing
g6 out of the spanish so what do you think
about this and is jan just trying to get a kind
of less familiar position he's playing a strong
opponent but maybe he feels the pressure to win
i think so um especially with the white pieces
i think that he at least feels the pressure to
to draw um can you explain what the white
pieces are and but once again nipoy is a
super strong player i mean he's one of the
best players in the world so it's gonna
be really tough it's really cool to see these
very strong people playing in this tournament
because every team can have one free agent so it's
really really exciting to see the super strong uh
players playing here and yeah now he's going for
c3 a6 is this theory robert yeah it's so kind of
like it's funny because playing like a sideline
in a way but theory within that sideline and at
the super grand master level they kind of know not
everything they're not full perfect information at
all times but they know most of these sidelines
here and look at this move bishop e2 you've given
up a pawn in the center and then drop the bishop
back but the reason white is going for this is
ideally you get to take back on d4 with your pawn
and have a beautiful center or if you take on c3
knight takes e3 white has three minor pieces out
compared to one for black maybe we'll see a bishop
g5 a quick castle and that's how black can get
under attack yeah so typically when white goes
for a gambit that's sort of the idea that at least
they want to get something for the pawn and um
attack and peace development i guess it's what
they're trying to go for in this position here
so it's uh it's quite common to be giving away
sometimes this this d4 pawn in different openings
and now we can see that black is going for d3 so
black is giving back the pawn but perhaps slowing
a bit the development for white that's absolutely
true and this pawn on c3 blocks the knight's jump
out so that's why young gives the pawn back
sometimes it's not worth stealing the material
if it comes to such a cost of giving white that
rapid development so let's uh we'll keep an eye
on this game we'll go around to some others
as well i see that anton korobov is playing a
very strong grand master from ukraine representing
the spare bank trade union and in this position i
caught my eye because there's a queen on h4 and i
know we may be familiar with ideas like this some
of our viewers may not it looks kind of scary
for black right with a queen on the king side
definitely i mean every single time that there's
a queen on the king's side you have to have a look
up for it and just like you're saying that h7
pawn could become a weak point i don't know if
at some point there could be any ideas of
going knight g5 and trying to push for e5
somehow that could definitely be uh that could
definitely lead to some sort of an attack but it
seems like uh varkomsky is going for for an attack
and we'll have to see if kraboff can defend this
and one of the ways to fend off an attack
is by striking back toward the center it
seems counterintuitive right if i'm getting
attacked on the king side don't have to put
all my pieces there but if you can attack in
the center then white's pieces cannot just go
free on the king side they'll have to respond
so b6 played that looks like a slow move with
a queen on h4 but knight g5 for example doesn't
threaten the checkmate just yet and maybe black
has time to just play h6 anyway and black is
trying to play bishop to b7 maybe knight to c5
it's all about timing you can't just make
these moves without thinking because white
will try to push an e5 type of move at some point
but korboff's so experienced he understands that
for now he's all right and the evaluation
bar says just as much yeah exactly so we
yeah so he can't really go knight to five yet just
like you said and there will have to be a sort
of correct move order if there's going to be any
attack here but um going bishop b7 i think that's
a that's a great move placing the bishop on b7
just to have this full diagonal and like you said
try to take a bit control of the center counter
attacking in the center that's what you want to do
if white is attacking on the king's side so uh
i think that this definitely no direct attack
yet but i think it could lead to some
really interesting positions this game
that's right and i'm gonna go to one of the
games in the match of we have pt um playing
against morgan stanley hungary and so we're gonna
switch matches here uh to show this game on board
four chelsea monica who streams who is 22.50
playing against international master ryosuke
nanjo japanese international master very strong
matchup here and the last one play was b4 so this
position out of sicilian white has thrusted g
pawn off the board black has put his b pawn so
anna you look at this position right black kings
and center white king the same what to make of it
i think it looks like a pretty crazy position
um it's like the type of position where you know
any player could sort of if they play a little
inaccuracy that could really change the whole game
and but i don't know if they if they have prepared
us i can see that chelsea that monica she's been
thinking for a little bit so i don't really know
if she if she had prepared for for a position like
this but i'm really happy to see her playing in
this tournament just like you mentioned she's
a fellow streamer on twitch and you know she's a
great streamer and she's also a very strong chess
player so it's really fun to see her playing
in this tournament and playing in this match
definitely and knight d1 you know while she's
of course experienced and she may be familiar
with some of the ideas based on clock management
thus far it feels like black sort of has the upper
hand and what worries me is white has nowhere to
castle because you put a pawn on g5 on the other
side the board you put your pawn a4 so your king
could get caught in the center whereas black could
play bishop e7 and castle into an impending attack
but at least your king if it needs to can get out
of the center so that concerns me typical ideas
like d5 at some point for black maybe right now
look pretty decent for a riosuke nanjo and
i don't know this is starting to look pretty
good for morgan stanley hungary on board four
yeah i totally agree with you and that point is
a very good point that you're making that white
is going to have a very difficult time castling
if white will probably not be able to castle
the king's side and castling queen side also
seems very dangerous whereas black just has the
simple idea of going bishop e7 castling and then
perhaps attacking the king and d5 is a great move
as it opens up the center which is something that
you would want to do when the king is still in the
center and can't hassle yet that's how this game
could go like d5 bishop b7 everything breaking
open and oftentimes with a king in the center oh
that move was not engine approved but the engine
isn't exactly on the highest depth so sometimes
it takes a while to register but d5 i think was
the thematic move it would have protected this
pawn on b4 as well not that you mind that pawn
being captured because if the queen takes it
then move like d5 will hit the queen and open
the sender so this is actually going to be a
very tense battle i think it's going to come
down to white's king safety but if she could
stabilize she will have the advantage and whoa
that move not appreciated by the engine at all
going up to plus two point something so there
must be some tactic and i think it starts with
f4 kicking the knight and you can even think about
f5 or even e5 to close down the center and then
play for an attack from there there being many
tempos won by white now after knight went to e5
if the black knight wouldn't have gone g5 then
moves like f4 would not have been possible but
she's going for a5 instead here makes sense
right hitting the knight on b6 i think one
of the things that can be difficult is like
move order and figure out wait do i attack
that knight or attack the knight to center do i
attack both and you can mix up ideas not because
these are very strong chess players they're titled
chess players but the problem becomes when they're
too many attractive options in a position we
sometimes go for both and maybe only one works
at a time yeah you know have you heard about all
these stories of some super gms not knowing which
rook to take and thinking or super long about you
know if they should take rick h d1 or or go rook
81 in some positions and there's the story with
old anderson that he played a correspondence chess
and you know it took him one week to decide which
rook he was going to bring to d1 because there
were so many different opportunities so it can
be tough to to know what move order to choose
that's an amazing story of anderson of course a
legend of chess and one of the best players uh
in his generation so if he took a week to decide
maybe that would mean a month for all of us and
well there was a capture on d5 recapture but
i was talking about white's king being unsafe
now it's looking like black's king because f4 is
coming the d5 pawn's under attack even if the king
does get castle to g8 still doesn't feel that safe
so i think we should leave the players to figure
it out on this board we'll go within this match
i see that muhammad ludwi ali the international
master on board one with a black piece against
international master lavon bergadzi that's the
cool thing about this tournament all these teams
are very strong the average team rating for
each team in the uh playoffs is at least 22.70
i think it goes from 2270 it's like 24 something
and remember three of the four players are members
of that company our work employees there rather so
their employees are very talented chess players
and anna in this position we see the two bishops
for white but white is down upon and the entrance
is zero so of course that means a dead draw right
well more than a dead draw i would say that it
means that there is there is enough compensation
for white so if white is upon down but the engine
says that it's equal it typically means that the
activity that white has um equals one pawn so
that means that white has a lot more activity
and has and has compensation for that pawn
basically so i definitely don't think that this
is gonna end up in a draw just because of that you
know just one of my quick comments about how the
engine can mislead us and to think about zero the
players are not thinking in this way they look at
this position and if you're international master
ali here you're saying well i have an extra pawn
so maybe i can figure out how to free my pieces
up and use my material advantage and international
master brigadzi saying your pieces can't move my
rook's coming to d7 my bishop on e4 is fantastic
attacking the knight on c6 and that
pawn on b7 behind it while protecting c2
and this bishop on b6 taking away d8 no truck
trades for you protecting f2 if they were ever
to be in trouble i think it's easier to play this
position from the white side if i'm being honest
yeah absolutely and i think that this sort
of comes to what type of player you are some
people like to be upon down have a little
or be a pawn up have a little extra material
and just try to defend the whole position and you
know just basically say you are not going to be
able to win from this position i'm going to defend
until we get into an engineer where i'm upon
up whereas other people really like playing
upon down but having a lot of activity because
then their pieces are a lot more active they can
sort of pressure their opponent down and it's i
think it's more a matter of preference what what
you prefer well i prefer being up over two minutes
on the clock so i do like white's position uh
even without the clock situation but especially
taking that into account it looks dangerous we do
have results i'm going to go over to that match
and spare because jan napomishi has been held to a
draw or you could say held his opponent to a draw
but i'm a little confused because this position
looks anything but drawish this is a wild position
so uh just getting word to see who offered this
draw you know it looks like black made the final
move but why is this a draw this king is in
the open white has one fewer rook but also one
extra minor piece and this attack right move like
knight to e4 can start so a bit surprised that a
draw offer would be accepted at this point yeah
i'm a bit surprised too i don't know if it has
anything to do with the fact that well white is a
bit better because of the whole the whole attack
and you know all the pieces and everything so
i don't know if white was just content with
making a draw because they were playing against
nippo and sometimes that's sort of the case
they're playing against a super strong player
but i definitely think that if white had the
opportunity that they should have kept on going
here and that's a grand master of the yp's in
a single game of course anwar can beat jana
palmache so surprising to us but let's keep
going within this match we have board two
is alexander kadetsky taking on uh yuri
i'm trying my best i haven't studied my rush in
a long time so anyway in this position you see
that even by material all four minor pieces on the
board but look at this jumping into this f5 square
because the queen protects the knight
that could be a problem for black trying
to figure out which bishop do i give up do i
take on f5 giving up the light square bishop
do i allow white to take on g7 giving the dark
square bishop or maybe i should just retreat
my bishop to f8 which is played but then the
e5 pawn that feels like more of a target that
is definitely going to be a target and
i don't even know if you could perhaps
take advantage of the fact that the bishop
is on g3 and it's spinning this pawn on e5
and go something like knight d4 to really exchange
black's pair of bishops oh actually knight d4
looks like an excellent good call the pawn is not
just under attack but it's pinned so at knight
f5 there it is a good call and a knight f5 to d4
trying to get this bishop and he can't move so
black's king is the worst of the two there's more
space that's available for white's pieces in front
of it if you say take on d4 knight takes d4
then i'll take your bishop play bishop g4
come after you on the diagonal this looks very
scary yeah i definitely really like this for white
um so we can see you know how annoying a pin can
be that pawn and e5 would have stopped the knights
from from ever going to d4 but because the pawn is
pinned and the queen is on c7 um why it's allowed
to play this and this looks great and that's great
for spare because yonder palm she held that draw
in a tough position and now they're bored too with
the white pieces in great shape so that could be a
lead for spare but let's see what's happening on
board three because maxime lavrov with the black
pieces um well he's up how many pawns it's only
one pawn it looks like more but this should be
a winning position for black sometimes one pawn
is not enough but anna here it looks like the
pawn structure is better for black you have more
material so it shouldn't be too difficult yeah
especially they have also the same color bishop um
if there would have been different color bishops
perhaps white could have tried to exchange queen
somehow and then go for that end game which is a
bit more difficult to to win with different color
bishops but because they have the same color
bishops as well it's probably going to be quite
easy for black to win this and one of the ideas
is okay white can go and try to take these queen
side pawns and then black would play h4 h3 and
actually try to checkmate the white king and this
bishop on f1 is bad another idea is queen e3 check
queen f2 and you actually might trap this bishop
weirdly enough it just doesn't have much space
so the bishop on e6 is excellent the bishop on
f1 is actually quite bad very few squares to
work with so i think this is going to be a win
for spare and if they win this game and cadets
get a great position they will take the match so
we'll keep our eyes out just be on the lookout but
let's go on to other games where we haven't uh
checked in on this game between fyodor mishakov
and voracek raza what's happening this king is
castled on c8 and a queen trade is being offered
and white's turn so and do you think you
should keep the queens on the board your king
is in the center for white or should you just
trade them and have the two bishops in an end game
well i think that in this exact
position the queen doesn't really have a
have a lot of squares to go to where it wouldn't
be traded so the only place i can see where the
queens would not be traded would be to go queen
g3 but because the king is in the center and you
know the bishop would be pinned on e2 i think
that it makes more sense to at least offer a
queen trade again so you can see bishop f3 now
white is offering a queen trade again and they're
trading queens here that's right this is board
three match up between enfie solutions and spare
bank trade union and the queens have been traded
the pawn has gone to e3 for what look at this
pawns in the center here they're in red because
that's how black is seeing them like oh i don't
like that that's that's painful but f5 what a way
to strike because if e5 look at this bishop on d2
the dark squares are clogged by white's pawns and
that's why white takes an f5 to keep the bishops
open but now the e file is open maybe black has
some counter play or anna do you think that white
should just be able to increase the pressure i
think that that bishop pair is going to be very
strong for white now the bishop is pinning the
knight on d6 and it feels like black is a bit
restricted with with their movement this bishop is
going to e7 and perhaps black will have some ideas
of going g5 but then that will give the e5 square
for the bishop so i feel like white's bishops are
really really strong and the king while the king
is now castling so the king is gonna be safe
white is also gonna be able to take advantage
of the e file being open and i really prefer
white here i agree and one thing that
was almost there for black was bishop h4
rook h4 g5 the problem is it's not a fork because
white can get away with bishop takes d6 with check
and end up a piece up otherwise this would be a
great decision for black did not work out because
of the check and so g5 was played and oh gosh now
rook's on the seventh rank you have the bishop
pair i think a material is about to fall that's
what it looks like you can just slide your other
the e1 oh didn't like that move because g4 g4 and
bishop g5 check and the rook on h7 is not defended
wow oh no that's how everything is taking a turn
here and that's a big problem because after g4
and it's played yeah that's a big turnaround and
it was looking so nice the rook should have went
to h1 to reinforce the other rook and now after
g4 that rook is not protected and bishop g5
is a i mean how is it can you stop it i don't
see any way i guess you have to take on d6 ah
okay so you don't lose material because
bishop b6 bishop d6 we trade rooks and
then i guess black is slightly better because
the advanced pawns but it is opposite color
oh but it's not going just wait that's a
piece that's a piece that's just the piece
wait wait but there's what okay didn't take it
because i guess this ensuing end game it was the
bishop pair that looked nice now there's
g okay but g takes f3 rookie seven check
king c8 this pawn's under attack neither side
feeling that comfortable in this tactical
situation but black had that if it had just
taken on f3 instead we have a slightly better
position for black because the knight can go
from color complex to color complex the pawn a6
could become a target in the near future but
ana that was a pretty wild tactical sequence
and it felt like the players were not ready for it
definitely i totally agree this was definitely a
very exciting tactical sequence and i think that
neither have neither of us saw that coming which
probably um reza didn't really see either when he
played rookie one so yeah it was really important
to go rook h1 and reinforce the other work there
on on h7 he seemed to have a great position before
but now it has turned around and mishakov is going
to be the one that's going to try to go for the
win here for sure that a6 pawn is weak i have to
go to this game because i see two seconds left an
internationally clogged and now down in exchange
so it looks like morgan stanley hungary is going
to take this all i am match up on board one that
apon is running very easy to keep pushing it a6
rook b7 a7 you're gonna win this bishop so i just
saw a couple seconds remaining and as we tuned in
it looks like white was winning material and
thus taking this game so that's a big win for
morgan stanley they'll be thrilled they've been
playing really well throughout the group stage
and well that's just easy at this point so we'll
get out of this one morgan stanley taking it uh
let's go to another matchup within this one here
chelsea monica this game still very sharp despite
the queens being off and now we have opposite
colored bishops with d4 anybody oh there it is
there it is that's another tactical woman wow
i mean robert you're just finding the games at
their prime i'm just you know i see it we have to
move on i just pick a game and it turns out that
there was a tactical moment there the rook on h1
was under attack d4 opened that bishop up and it's
still not easy to win this actually i could see
white winning this game if you get your pawn to
d4 and play pawn to b5 you get a breakthrough on
the queen side and the rook for the bishop dynamic
that doesn't mean as much if there's a past pawn
heading your way and this king is coming up to c4
and i actually think i prefer white's chances
at this point i think that just like you're
saying white has a lot of practical chances and
especially with one minute versus 20 seconds i
think that black could feel very pressured i know
a lot of times when i play and you know my i am an
exchange shop two rigs on my opponent has a bishop
i mean that bishop can become so strong and can
sometimes become better than a rook and i think
that we might be seeing that in this game perhaps
and the nerves and look at chelsea monica
at over a minute to 20 seconds for black
and that's what happens when you play a lot
of blitz especially online you are accustomed
to situations like this where you don't know
who's better you're trying to assess on the fly
and both of you are getting in time travel but the
pawns on d6 this pawn can go to a7 and that bishop
protects a7 and stops the pawn from getting
to f2 while protecting d6 is doing it all and
rook f7 behind the pass from this king can come
into c6 white has two past pawns black has one
and yet the eval bars is completely even i mean
that's that's not what the players are thinking
that's not how they play your sphere like net feel
right now but bishop is a very nice move to just
stop the f-punk from pushing now you guys see that
black is trying to to go for these checks perhaps
i don't know if they want to try to get a
repetition but no what a brave move by the
way king to e5 like just moving the king allowing
the past pawn to go and it still says even somehow
they're playing accurate moves here completely
even position it looks to me like white should
be uh punching the pawns through first but of
course d7 drops the rook on d3 and now he likes
black because the a7 pawn christine the pawn
the pawn was hanging and now king b7 there's
rook to f8 so what is happening here what is
happening this looks absolutely insane white
is a full work down but has these two extremely
strong past pawns i think this could sort of go
anyway i guess there's eight at some point but
i oh okay it's when rook b1 watch out for v8 so
let's play rook a8 so you can take this pawn yeah
why have to be very careful to not drop any pawn
because that would change the whole dynamic of the
position that's right that would actually probably
end in a loss rook take rookie d7 i think it's
only saved rook f7 check well that was actually
pretty clever by black to allow the rook to be
take on d7 you're going to win the a7 pawn and
rook and h pawns almost never winning oh
don't don't take me check me oh my gosh
oh my gosh what a trick by ryosuke nanjo setting
up a meeting net oh my gosh that was so so tricky
and that's what he was setting up a trap
by bringing the king to d5 because he saw
that she can go rook b8 he saw that he could sack
the rook and that the king went to e8 rook a7 rook
b5 check is a good move but after king e6 you need
to move your king out of the opposition black's
king takes away the squares rook takes h5 a fatal
error that is checkmate with a lone broken king
that was i mean this just shows how quickly
a game can turn around they played so well
in the time pressure with you know a very
difficult position to play with because
of all the material imbalances but we can see
that the game can completely turn around in one
move just like this and look at this
the score it's 2-2 that tied the match
that was a critical victory wow we're gonna go
to the other game still going on here because
uh we see that elena hamiakova with the white
pieces she's winning this game against marlena
uh chose so it looks like the pawns are just
pushing g6 g7 bishop c4 should do the trick
king on g6 that's not gonna help your cause you
need to push the g pawn through so i think should
figure this out the second time around there
it goes g7 bishop c4 g7 actually is mate g7h7
at that point but okay this is easily winning so
king f7 getting queens let's go the other game
uh remaining here that's this is board four
and let's go to the other game here oh this
is winning we have a rook end game the king gets
out if a king comes closer you throw in the check
and then you get your queen yeah famous famous
rook end game igor yanich for empty solutions
takes that game over afghani kritov and wow so
this match is oh excuse me that's for spare bank
uh trade uni took the two and a half half lead and
so even though yanez wins the game it's not enough
a two and a half one half victory for spare bank
trade union oh my gosh and i still can't get over
that checkmate that we just saw with the rook
on the a final move i cannot get over that one
either and i think that that probably hurt a lot
to lose in that way that's one of the ways that
hurts most to lose by just losing you know in one
move with a trick like that but it was very clever
um it was very clever to set up this type of trick
because you know practically with this little time
it was very easy for that to happen obviously
you just want to get the the pawn out of there
and just you know say all right you're going to
have to fight for a draw but this is just a draw
but no that was just a check made in one move
there so wow incredible game so much pressure
right on the clock we were just talking about
chelsea monica she streams she has a lot of blitz
so i thought she would be the one who was
more accustomed to that situation maybe she is
but these things happen as we know we
play a ton of blitz you have a good game
things are going your way and suddenly you missed
checkmate one because it came out of nowhere so
we do have all matches done we couldn't get every
single game under our attention unfortunately
but we know that the results as such spare takes
down erg that's good for yon napomneshi and
he made that draw in a tough position that
was kind of a fortunate escape for him and
spare bank trade union beats empty solutions
two and a half one half we had a tie two to
two between morgan stanley hungary and uh pt and
we in our final match of the um around here we
had gronke bank beating anawak two and a half one
half led by georg meyer on board one he scores a
victory for gronkey as did alina kashlinskaya the
free agent on board two she helps that team out so
grunky moves on we will have a blitz match i guess
because of the tiebreaks let me just confirm with
the team uh what's going on yup let's see if we
get a blitz match there between morgan stanley and
that would be very very exciting
to to get a blitz match i think
it's always more exciting with the
little or the lower time control and
these games have already been extremely exciting
so i would really look forward to getting a blitz
match there so we're gonna see if we are going to
be getting that but i have to say that even though
we were not able to watch every single game here
i do think that you know we found some really nice
moments and happy that we were able to to follow
these these very exciting moments live like for
instance the rick checkmate or all of the other uh
tactical moments where we joined in so thank you
i agree and i still can't believe that uh anwar
accepted that draw against jan napomnishi because
it's clear that the team from spare is super
strong they were the number one overall rated
team on average and i know it's jana pomshi but
anwar's grand master very strong player in his
own right and accepting a draw in that position
it felt like it was letting jan off the hook
absolutely especially when he had such a great
position so yeah probably perhaps should have
continued the game but um i'm sure he had his
reasons but but yeah it seemed to be a very good
opportunity for them and for that team especially
when you're playing in a team right because every
every result can really make a big change for
everybody yeah it's certainly the case and we're
getting word that uh there is gonna be ten minutes
before the next round the players are going to
get settled there is going to be the whole team
playing three minute plus two second increment
blitz so if you were here just to play some rapid
chess think again the players are going to have to
test their medal in blitz games against the other
team and we just remind everybody that while we're
having great chess we're having a good time there
also is money being raised for various initiatives
fide doing a great job raising funds for players
with disabilities for veterans who you know have
played chess throughout their careers and need
some support and chess and education so if
you're able to click on the button and the twitch
channel please use the command for corp donate and
you any generosity is extremely appreciated if
you can so we are going to go on a brief break
when we return a couple minutes we'll get
set for the blitz tie break four games go
on at once we'll need to catch our breath
stay tuned everybody we'll be right back
and we return in the playoff stage of the
fide online world corporate chess championship
anna this was an exciting round four
matchups three have been decided
and we're about to have blitz tie breaks the
best type of tie breaks it's going to be super
exciting i'm really looking forward to this
and yeah here we can here we can see the format
so we can see that the top team and well we can
see yeah we're already in the playoff playoffs
well i was going to say and uh are your vocal
chords right you said you're excited but are
your vocal cords excited for the fast-paced
blitz that we're about to see with three minutes
and two second increment my vocal cords are super
excited i know that yours are amazing for this
robert and mine are gonna match this i'm ready for
it i believe that every step of the way and if the
blitz match is tied two to two just like the uh
rapid match was then we will be sent to armageddon
and armageddon is something in chess where one
player the player the white pieces gets five
minutes black gets four minutes no increment white
will need to win that game black can draw the game
and that would count as a win for the player with
the black piece so draw odds to black tie mods to
white it's always exciting to see armageddon
and the teams actually nominate a player
it's very likely that they'll nominate their top
board but it's also possible that maybe one of the
other boards is a blitz specialist speed demon
and so you choose that player but that's only an
event that we have a tie we see the morgan stanley
team we have them behind the scenes here you can
see them now they're getting ready some of them
were stretching i'm sure there are nerves i'm
sure there's you know they're very proud of each
other just to be in this playoff and then to tie
two to two but they'll have to get their mouse
ready each player because sometimes there's no
thinking in blitz dress you just gotta move you
just gotta move i was gonna ask robert what do
you prefer in armageddon do you prefer playing
with the white pieces or with the black pieces
oh gosh i would say at it's kind of 50 50 in many
regards i would prefer to have the black pieces
but it also depends on like what happened
before that if i let's say you're playing
a classical term and then your the end is some
kind of tiebreaker but if you want a bunch of
games i want the white pieces i'm going to go
for that win or say ah i drew the last couple
games just down the stretch let's just hold
and make the draw i would and if i'm playing
someone higher rated i also would probably want
the black pieces because you know beating them
is very difficult so trying to make that draw
it's a hard choice to make what would you choose
a part of me agrees but then there's another
part of me that just always likes to go for
the win and you know i really like playing with
the white pieces i feel like my openings are a
lot better with the white pieces so same time i
don't know i think i would prefer to play with
the white pieces and try to go for a win but it
really depends on the opponent just like you said
and well we do have liftoff not quite an
armageddon yet starting with a three minute
plus two second increment blitz c3 played by
international master ali trying to get d4 in
and that's why bishop g4 is often played let me
take your knight at some point and soften the d4
square but i think white can just push this pawn
that doesn't stop it and h3 played first offering
the exchange so anna a quieter opening to start
with in this game but i like white's position
yeah i play stuff that is similar to this
uh with black um so i i kind of like the
ideas for black as well but this is white white
does have quite an active position and just like
you said the idea is for white at some point to
try to take as much center as possible by going
d4 which is why black wanted to go bishop g4 to
to to stop d4 immediately and now that's why also
they've going bishop h5 instead of trading because
they want to keep that pin there to avoid d4 being
played and i like that white has not played d4 yet
instead of castling if you play d4 there could be
a quick strike for black in the center thanks to
this pin so i'm agreeing with you here a6 played
you can take that knight double the pawns and
that was played at some point you can go queen a4
this is a known idea to break the pin by getting
aggressive and i think queen a4 could be a very
useful move of course you can just develop your
pieces and white has a lead in development but
if black gets out the bishop pair should be good
let's move on to another game because i just see
the chord in my eye this one pawns are storming
that was more of a positional battle to start
with this says positional chest come on this is
trying to get g6 trying to get h6 but black hasn't
castled so it's possible that farida for monsieur
says okay you're trying to attack me there
my king's running the other direction that's the
thing when white goes for an attack this early
when black hasn't decided where to castle okay
now black actually made a choice by going rook
c8 because now they've decided they're not
gonna castle queen side which is a what would
lead to perhaps a more positional position
because it wouldn't be this race if you know
uh of black which is what's gonna what's um
yeah which is what we're perhaps going to be
seeing now but um king b1 was played and i don't
know if the king is gonna stay in the center on
e8 or if they're gonna go ahead and castle i
think they have to castle at some point but
then these pawns are gonna become very strong on
g5 and h5 yeah super scary to castle but if you
do castle and g6 is played black can shut it down
with h6 so whichever pawn pushes for white if you
play h6 black will play g6 if you play g6 black
will play h6 kind of deal so that allows black
to castle but it won't feel truly safe until
you trade the queens off the board for example
because that king with those pawns storming could
be dangerous exactly and black's pond can't really
push yet because they sort of need to see what
white does with their pawns so they're going to
have to stay in this initial position and okay
now they're deciding to castle okay castle what
it happened so i mean taking on f5 makes sense
and maybe some kind of knight f4 knight g3 first
so take the pawn oh h6 is coming okay wow what a
decision to play f6 because just a move ago if you
played like b6 random move h6 you can no longer
play g6 and shut it down because there would be
a checkmate so that's why black f6 himself
saying you're not getting in with your queen
and now after g6 and h6 we can see that
there's been a sort of lock on the king side
attack there so rookie one was played to to put
some pressure on e6 and now rick c6 also too to
help out on on uh defending e6 so if it's like
there's not gonna be as much attack on the
black king anymore and another trying to double
up rooks on the e file yeah it's all about this
pawn now because black has to sit and defend this
pawn white's rooks are active and the rook on e2
just like the rook on c6 defends and attacks there
could be some kind of g4 g5 if black isn't careful
you give up a pawn to break open the position
because in the event of the pawn going to g5 which
is not happening but if the pawn went to g5 and
black 2 with the h pawn you play h6 to break open
the king side but i like this move queen g4 you're
just forcing black in a sense to play a move like
rookie 8 and sit defending while white's pieces
are perfectly placed attacking so i like the
position for peter lizack let's go to another
game just to see what's happening uh wow okay
this position i see a knight on g5 a rook on g1
ryosuke nanjo the hero the japanese international
master saved the day for morgan stanley and then
wait there's an attack on the queen side for black
a potential attack in the center for white there's
a king here who's attacks coming first anna
that's that's a great question i kind of feel
like black's attack is going to be a little bit
faster because that a4 pawn is hanging now so it
feels like black's pieces are really going to be
um are really going to be getting into attack
for instance if rick takes a4 now there's gonna
be some rookie one threat immediately so um i
feel like black is a little bit faster but now
now the e file is getting open and white has a
great rig on e1 so it feels like now white is
worth solidifying uh their whole position yeah
with this b3 move that's a pawn chain now going
after the defense actually this has been very
good play from both sides maybe some of the moves
catching us off guard but i think high quality and
bishop d2 what a move just to go after the b4 pawn
and the queen can also slide up to f4 or somewhere
else to uh the f7 pawn was under attack so bishop
d5 attacks it defends as a great bishop i think
i like white's chances because this king is
on d8 that doesn't look very safe white's king
actually looks quite safe for the time being yeah
for now definitely the only thing that could
perhaps be problematic are those dark squares
in front of the white king but i think that
white would be able to would probably be able
to offend that and there's not really any clear
way for black to take advantage of that yet
i'm looking at rook takes a4 at some point because
then the queen gets in here their checkmating
ideas down on the a2 and a1 squares but this king
is in the center and if your attack doesn't work
out you're just lost right you're sacrificing
a rook for a couple pawns so rook a6 played i
think that's a there might be a knight c5 queen
b8 check that's that actually wins a pawn that
went to pawn oh did not see that but that's maybe
not the easiest thing to spot right there but it
doesn't work the second time but knight takes
e5 was available i'll show that very quickly
the point everyone is after takes takes queen
v8 the queen has to block you trade queens
at the end of the line the rook takes the bishop
you net upon and black's king is still in trouble
so that was missed hard to see with no time in the
clock let's uh just check the other game that we
haven't looked at it's a little bit more locked
up and we see that white infiltrating with the
queen on d6 just like that other game the e6 pawn
petra pop in trouble here she's to go to a passive
defense with knight to g7 white's position
looks amazing i definitely agree this is sort
of the dream position you want to have when
you're playing against an isolated pawn and
isolated backwards found that we can as that's
the one on e6 and now you know they're even
bringing this knight to f4 probably to add some
extra pressure on the e6 pawn so every single
piece of white is going to be attacking that e6
pawn that's just a dream but we can see now that
black played queen f6 you put some pressure
on this d4 pawn so the knight cannot move yet
so we can see that black is trying trying to get
some play there as well that's right g5 trying to
open things up that knight can get to f4 g3 is
under attack the rook's hanging don't bond the
rook where that move was not approved of so may
is an e5 and d4 kind of there it is step one but
didn't like that move so i was looking the same
thing so i can't blame uh petropap but this this
eval bar this is blitz for you you don't have
enough time to calculate everything things are
happening before you wait f4 again oh wow oh that
was a fork and now white wins material another
queen queen oh gosh that's a free queen and that's
a free queen and we saw her she couldn't believe
it and she's distraught okay let's uh go back to
the games here she is uh pretty unhappy that was
a big wait queen wasn't taken but she's down
two rooks for night so let's go on to a new game
let's go to this one here between lavon bergadzi
and mohammed uh lofty al excuse me this is an
end game where it's anyone's position because
that pawn d3 looks really strong you need your
rook to attack the king and then this a pawn
could start rolling if you're not careful so
wow what is who's better even material but
it feels like at first glance black should
be better yeah that pawn on d3 is real advanced
yeah yeah the pawn on d3 is super advanced so
it feels like black should be better but um i mean
the pawn on d3 could also become a target if black
is not really careful so and if the bishop moves
watch out for a4 a5 a6 i mean that punk can run
yep that pawn can run definitely and you know that
e6 pawn is also quite weak so i think that as long
as as long as that d3 pawn doesn't get doesn't
get to promote basically this is totally fine
for white and i think that you should be able to
defend that but rick says have three now there's
there's a pawn hanging there as well it's true but
that pawn can run in a fight it's one to one by
the way we saw the match even up we have another
game going it is a rook end game and king c6 can
win this pawn but even if you win that pun you
should not win this game with the black pieces
because these are double pawns to win end games
you need past pawns double pawns do not help you
create past pawns but you have to be careful
not to allow this black king in because uh oh
that can't get coming to e3 if you're not careful
give me three and that could be some checkmate you
have to pincy one you have to go qc1 you just
checkmated in this manner the king can hide on
b2 well what if you take king takes take on b4 you
have rook c4 check so you do survive barely barely
surviving oh don't allow king c3 that's you cannot
allow this should be a draw with proper play but
not easy in the end game we're going to go quickly
back to the other game we got to go back and forth
white took a pawn and that pawn's going to a7 this
is anyone's match it looks like here for pt they
have the advantage now but at any moment rugby
two check could happen d2 could happen and then
it could be black winning this game so oh my god
anything could happen here it's uh hold on a queen
oh no oh my gosh stepped in line that's
that's what we're saying anything can happen
and that's going to be a win for pt with the white
pieces up a queen and checkmate on the board with
the bishop and let's go to the other game because
now pt has a 2-1 lead and they need a win does
morgan stanley hungry this pawn is on b7 that
gives them a fighting chance ryusuke nanjo was
the player who won that game one with rook against
rook essentially and unfortunately rook b2 happens
i don't know if chelsea monica has seen
the results of her teammates you're in
the middle of your own bullet time scramble
but she's doing the trick here king here just
go i would go rook see a check please take the
pawn but look at this yeah she has to try it
now she makes the draw do you make the draw and
morgan stanley hungary is eliminated they clawed
their way back just to get to the blitz tie break
and unfortunately we'll go back to that position
really oh no we won't we're oh yes we will sorry
to my producer for making his life as difficult as
possible we have to go back to this moment here
because black steals a pawn in the center and
that's like well you're you're doing great like
you're up a pawn now your pawns on d3 but somehow
this pawn went from a3 to a7 before you know it
and the bishop is covering the a8 square and just
a move king d5 that looks so natural you only have
one other king move and you tend to want to avoid
the color that your opponent's bishop is on right
when we're facing opposite colored bishops we want
to stay on our own bishop's color unfortunately in
this case that allowed the pawn to promote because
that bishop needed the full line of sight to the
a8 square enna we've all lost blitz games like
this i mean what can you say for morgan stanley
hungary to go down in this way when you were just
on the cusp of going to an army game keeping this
match tied yeah it really does hurt and we've
seen in this whole match we've seen a lot of these
type of little tactics that have won the game like
for instance you know here king d5 a8 that's the
queen or in the other match where there was this
or there was this checkmate with the rook and so
there have been a lot of a lot of you know one
move tricks in this match but that's just part of
chess and especially in faster time control such
as rapid and even more so in blitz this is this
is basically what happens and it it hurts to to
lose in this way but um i think that i think that
they've been playing great so we have seen really
amazing matches i think they should be happy with
their matches and yeah it's just uh at some points
you know being happy is not enough because this is
a competition you want to win that's the problem
you know it's unfortunate but what a fight what
a fight so let's uh look at the updated brackets
because we now know our final four we have spare
that's the yonder palm shield team on the top
uh left of the bracket taking on spare bank trade
union led by anton korbuff so we're about to have
a super grand master battle on board one between
those teams and gronka bank taking on pt i think
that gronkin bank is the big favorite in my
opinion led by georg meyer on board one the
extremely strong super solid grand master who
also is an amazing blitz player so if that
match is tied to two and they get to blitz i think
george can help spearhead that lineup and i really
believe that with a balanced lineup the rest
of the way i think it's even matchups on boards
uh two through four actually maybe gronky
even has a rating advantage on board too
i think that that advantage the gm i am matchup
on one leads gronkit to have the edge over pt
but anything can happen and anna we just saw pt
win this blitz tie break so maybe they're feeling
more motivated than ever yep that's what happens
if you win a game or chat of chess or if you win
a match you're gonna feel more motivated you're
gonna have more confidence and that is typically
going to be shown in your chess games a lot of
times we can see that those type of players are
a little bit more aggressive or play a little bit
faster and that can really uh that can really help
out practically in the game so they they could
have an edge because of the fact that they won
this match definitely that's right and gronkey is
one of the biggest supporters in the chess world
they have the grand cay classic and the ground can
open they have the bodenboden chess club and the
bundesliga and you know their the chess world will
be a lot worse without the support from grandkid
and for those of you who are here who have
been a part of this if you can please do
donate to the initiatives that fide has put
forth it's for players with disabilities for
veterans and also for chess and education so do
get involved please hit the panel in the twitch
stream use the command corp donate if you're able
to it would be greatly appreciated but for now
and i we need to take a break because that was
exciting i feel white's just seeing the finish
there we'll be back the rounds will begin
at about approximately half past the hour
so we'll take a brief break and we'll return
we'll get ourselves ready for the semi-finals
welcome back everybody to the feed a world
corporate championship finals grand master
robert hess alongside me anna kremling anna
we needed that break because we saw a blitz
tie break between morgan stanley hungary and
pt how are you feeling you recovered i have
recovered it took a while because uh it was a
pretty crazy thai break but i'm recovering now
and i'm ready for the semi-finals we will have
the semi-finals ahead we have a couple minutes
until then we just wanted to go over one moment
from a game that happened in the blitz match
and it was between peter lizack representing
morgan stanley hungary and fareed for manzi from
pt so the player with the black pieces moves on
with the team but in this position it looks pretty
difficult for black because white is having all
the fun here there's rook staring down at the e6
pawn the g6 pawn keeps that king on the back
rank but anna we see the engines say zero
so from experience what can you say in positions
like this where the engine tells you just shuffle
your pieces around how difficult is that to do
i think it's very difficult to do i think that
as a as a chess player you don't just want to
make random moves you want to have a plan behind
every move so to just be shuffling your pieces
around it's something that's not very intuitively
you want to you want to come up with plans and and
and you want to do stuff so it's very difficult
that's right and i look at the engines it's zeros
i look at the position zeros this looks like a fun
game to play especially in blitz and let's see how
this went because at this moment black one a5 you
see the evaluation starts to creep up in white's
favor and there as he gets more depth it sees
white's advantage growing a bit and the reason
why a5 is played is to go b4 and for an attack
the reason why that could backfire is now
the b5 pawn needs to have an eye kept on it
white with queen b3 black one
rook c4 okay defending the pawn
queen went to d3 and then b4 was played and white
said i'll just push through and now i'll play b3
my queen will come into a square like a6 or b5 and
black's problems still exist so it still says even
but the position is becoming increasingly
difficult for black to play because when you push
pawns forward you leave space behind and you don't
control the squares they once controlled so black
one b3 all in for the attack trying to double
rooks and that's the sign of a player who does not
like their position they think i'm going to lose
this game if i do nothing and anna check this out
rook takes e6 step one rook b8 okay defending
rookie two good move and look at this move
that's a that's a winner queen a7
that's a beautiful way to win a game
very pretty that king has this background problem
so if the queen takes the queen well then there's
going to be rookie checkmate um because the the
pawn on g6 is so strong it's taking away those
escape squares f7 and h7 so the king cannot
escape and that was a very beautiful tactic
and i think that was really cool with this game is
what you mentioned before that may perhaps if they
just shuffle the pieces around it's equal but i
thought that black's plan of pushing the pawns in
front of the king made a lot of sense i think it's
something that a lot of players would do because
you know you have to come up with some sort of
plan and pushing the pawns and creating an attack
for the king makes a lot of sense so i think it's
really cool to see how that could backfire that's
right and even if we go back to this move 21 and
as soon as you see this pawn here you forever
have to worry about your back rank so the position
became increasingly challenging for the black side
because that king can never quite get out so
a queen trade would help you but until those
queens come off your king's not running into the
center of the board and that's why i think white
maintained the pressure and ended up winning
the game unfortunately for peter lizac the
team did not move on but it was an instructive
moment nonetheless and okay we are getting set
for the semi-finals i am excited for it
so we have just two matches in this round
four games all four players on the team
play only in one game so yonder palm she
will be taking on anton korabov in a matchup
of the world's elite blitz players and rapid
players superstars but anna if you're the rest of
the team right you look at board one like i don't
know what's gonna happen there they can beat each
other how do you manage your own games while out
of the corner your eye looking at your teammates
it's very difficult i think it's something that
you have to kind of balance it you sort of
want to know how the team is doing to you know
sort of understand what what result your game
needs to finish in because obviously if all of
your teammates have won maybe you know there's
just you just need to make a draw for your team
to win which is the most important thing
but at the same time if you're constantly
focusing on every any everybody else's game
then you're gonna stop focusing on yours so
i think that most players what they typically do
is that they just focus on their own game and they
kind of take it as it comes and then you know
if they if they perhaps are offered a draw or
something they'll see how the team has done but
i think mostly they will be focusing on their own
games right and it's difficult because you add the
periphery you're looking and looks like games are
starting so let's actually pull this up here we
have yonder palms the white pieces against anton
corbin and we have a french so i am somebody who
does not like the french defense very much because
the bishop on c8 gets caught here but anna maybe
you have different feelings about this opening
i don't play the french i don't even play e4 as
white so i don't really see the french in a lot
of my own games but i think that i sort of feel
the same way that bishop on c8 does become really
bad and it becomes a bit difficult to play in
that regard but it's just preference some people
really like to play it that's right and
the bishop on c doesn't get out it's
stuck behind the wall of pawns and pieces but
though black plays it because often the underlying
structure is extremely solid you have this pawn
chain from f7 to d5 that makes your bishop worse
but your pawns feel safe and this is still
theoretical so i think we can come back here
in a bit uh they will this theoretical discussion
will continue they'll figure it out let's go on to
georg meyer in the grunky match against pt because
i was saying that this was the biggest advantage
for gronke the grand master against international
master and york meyer very strong grandmaster at
that but with the white pieces anna do you just
play solid chess and try to make a draw or do
you say i don't care about your rating it's an
individual game let's just play chess i am more of
the second type i like to just play out the games
i always want to play my best and even if george
meyer is a very high rate player obviously a draw
at four for for white here would be a good result
i think that you know you should just try to play
to play out the game and see how it comes but
i think that that's also what he's going to
try to do we'll see and york is thinking so
that indicates to me he's considering the capture
on f6 with the pawn otherwise you just take with
the queen right away and if you take with the
pawn that can give you some attacking chances
but it also gives you double pawns which may not
be the best situation so georg very experienced
in the french he is the maybe the leading expert
in the french in the world he is always playing
at his tried and true opening and anna what
do you think which way is going to take on f6
i think that gtx f6 is very interesting because
of that idea of of opening up the g-file and um i
mean i'm not really used to these positions but i
think that that really does look very interesting
so perhaps he's gonna actually take with the with
the g pawn perhaps thinking with the queen is a
little bit more solid but i think it can lead
to some very interesting positions i actually
think that sorry to interrupt you there i think
being solid can backfire in a position like this
and that's why he does take with the pawn
the great decision because this bishop
dominates the bishop on c8 this pawn b7 is under
attack so his main purpose in doing this is to try
to play this f5 move it's it's weird right we this
this is more solid like how could this be better
it's because if you try to take the solid
approach after say a take on d4 i probably
can take with the queen on d4 but i also can say
let's stop one move short there could be a queen
b5 check bishop takes b7 this king's in the center
and a move like that staring in both direction
black is underdeveloped and white is
fully developed with all the pieces flying
yeah i definitely think that just like you said
playing solid can backfire and i think that's one
thing a lot of times when somebody's trying to
play for a draw the problem with playing for a
draw is the fact that when you're just playing
trying to just play solid and play for a draw
you typically play quite passive and you
you can give your opponent a lot of chances
so that's why it's so important to always play
actively even if you want to draw in a game
that's right and i think that now speaking of
actively f5 for black bishop can come to g7 and
that's in part why york takes with the pawn on
f6 he can fianchetto this bishop long diagonal
to work with and the king can't steal castle king
side it's not unsafe over there so let's keep
in this match let's go to alina kashlinskaya on
board too she's the free agent this is a locked
up position where white has the bishop pair but
this is your quote-unquote extra bishop for one
of these knights that bishop can't find daylight
at least not for the time being because look at
black structure very typical way to say hey that's
not a disadvantage to have the knights yeah we can
see this big big big big big block of pawns here
in the center which is blocking the bishop but now
perhaps the bishop is going to get a little bit
more of light perhaps because now after d takes e4
well it's it's giving a few more squares for
the bishop but we can definitely see that this
bishop on g2 is not an amazing piece that's
right is a good piece and it can go to b3
attacks the pawn text the queen so i think that uh
international master for monsieur said all right i
don't want to open that bishop as you were just
highlighting but maybe tactically it will work
out for me and as you see on the evaluation
bar it says it's a completely even position
yeah this is another one of those though that i
think that the evil bar says that it's a it's an
equal position but there's just so much play here
uh there's this is gonna be a long game and you
know nothing is decided here i don't let's keep on
in this match we'll go to the next one with board
three hana marie kleck is board three for gronka
bank we have masuri raman board three for pt and
what is going on with these pawns here for why
these pawns here it's white's turn anna help me
out which pawn do we take do we have to take can
we leave it i'm confused i am very confused as
well that's the thing when you have all of
these pawns in the center and all of these
traits you just gotta think about you know
which pun is the one that we should take um i
think well right now uh i think that i kind of
like taking on d5 because it's it's upon that it's
a little bit less protected and um i don't know if
after knight takes there could be like perhaps i
don't know like okay yeah c4 perhaps it's not good
because knight before but okay it's taking on e5
um having the same show that we are i asked
you the question because i genuinely didn't
know what to do and uh he says i'm gonna take
on e5 rather than anything else and it seems
like with the series of trades black's position
looks pretty nice to me you're already castled and
i don't know i think that there's
no opening disadvantage whatsoever
yep i totally agree now white castle because they
had to castle as quickly as possible especially
all the center getting open very soon so it made
a lot of sense at the castle robert i have to ask
you you know you were you we were talking about
the french before and i saw somebody say that you
drew anon with a french at some point is that true
we don't talk about success in the french defense
it is true i i i did have uh you know one good
game in the french so uh you know we'll leave
it at that but uh here this position i think a
huge opening success for hannah marie kleck and
that's good news for grunke and let's go to board
4 in grand cay because that is inna agrest where
is her game there it is against chelsea monaco
so two very strong players these ratings that's
not their real raise they're like 2 300 each
not 2100 but even the 2100 level is very strong
so this position is very closed but white can play
for b4 at some point trying to pry open the queen
side and if you go rook to b1 that could help
you go after this b5 pawn so i would say anna the
biggest problem for black bad bishop bad bishop
and white's pieces get a little more activity
and you can play the king sides of boot yeah no i
totally agree um it's fun to see a swedish player
here that ina is playing it's really fun to
see that but um i definitely think that in
this position our pieces are more active and b4
immediately just seems like a very strong move
because of this pin once again with with the
queen um so i think that b4 immediately just
seems like a very active move and very strong
and that pawn on b5 could be under some pressure
after after an exchange but we can see that she
went for knight h4 she's she wants to place a
knight on f5 i think it was kasparov who said
that a knight on f5 is worth a pawn so knight
and f5 are always really good so it makes sense
that she wants to transfer that knight there
and she's realizing the tactics work in her favor
because when i see knight h4 and the bishop one
e7 i think wait a second my knight moves out
the way that knight can be captured in h4 but
if i take either on d5 or e4 it actually doesn't
really matter because uh there are several ways
to win this one is to go knight f5 and take this
bishop with check when you take the bishop on e3
you could also just play pawn takes a knight
and after bishop h4 my queen comes to h5 with
a checkmate threat and the bishop under attack so
you would actually lose the piste here for black
not recommended and rook once it takes takes
one rook pair of rooks to come off this knight
coming to f5 g6 can be played but then after g6
maybe that bishop gets into h6 so it said rook a8
and i think you should even trade these rooks
plant this pony on f5 and say i'm going to press
forward yeah i think that the issue here is the
fact that black pieces are pretty uncoordinated
but also very passive this we can see this bishop
on a8 is not doing anything and this bishop on f8
is is trying to defend a bit on the king side
and i think that white's pieces are just going
to start to such attack and become very active and
i think it's going to be hard for black to defend
i agree and the one thing you should be careful is
a file the only open file so if black can quickly
bring this queen down somewhere to attack the
pawns that could be a problem but white's there
first and this b5 pawn's in trouble because you
can't play c4 your pawn is pinned if you play b4
and she doesn't but b for that c4 square would
have been white's for the taking and that's
a great spot for the knight so queen a5 played
attacking the c3 pawn ultimately i think that's a
pretty decent choice but bishop takes b5 can still
be played and i like white's pieces and maybe
there's even after queen c3 and i did like bishop
c6 trying to encourage the trade get a past pawn
yeah black needs to try to find some type
of counter attack and obviously white still
needs to be careful but it seems as if white
does have the the better position here and the
better chances for this game certainly and let's
go to the other match we have jan napomischi take
on anton korbov we saw this early on in the french
now we're in a queenless position where there's an
isolated pawn on d5 that's not good news for
korreboven know what else is not good news
anna look at the clock situation very bad news
the clock situation what four extra minutes for
a nepo and what do you think can korvov hold off
he is a superstar he's a super grand master does
he have chances to hold this even though it looks
bad in the initial position i mean chances to hold
this i definitely think he has but he's going to
probably suffer in this end game because white's
plan is always going to be to put as much pressure
as possible on d5 by you know perhaps going rook
d1 perhaps even doubling works on d1 and also
you can see that white even has the the c file
open right now so even white's pieces are more
active than black's pieces in this position so
i definitely think that he's going to have a
tough time but holding it i think that there
are chances that he can hold this yeah i agree
it's a position where most players they look at
when you talk about holding this is okay for black
but i'm looking at yon na pamashi he is one of the
world's best players he's in the co-lead at the
candidate tournament which determines who plays
magnus carlson for the world chess championship so
i like white's position as you said let's go after
this pawn on d5 and if the pawn moves maybe that
helps my knight get into this d6 square using this
pawn e5 i think white has a very nice position
let's go to the second board here in this matchup
and here we go alexander kadetsky with
the black pieces against evgeny kretov
what's going on opposite-colored bishops
doubled pawns here and the last one
played was a5 i think we understand that this
bishop wants to do some work on the diagonal
it does it wants to find nice square and that b4
square is a nice square there's no pawn that can
attack it ever so it's going to be able to stay
there there's also no other minor piece that
could be exchanged for that before bishop so it's
going to be a very strong bishop now because that
white is going for the queen exchange here i was
about to say the queen exchange indicates to me
that white is probably i'm not really planning
to win this game i would love to win the game
but if black takes this c pawn can't go the bishop
and the rook team up on a dark square and perhaps
that c pawn becomes a weakness rather than the
strength the bishop can of course wrap around
the b5 square all is protected i think the most
likely result by far is a draw because neither
side will really be able to make too much progress
yeah i thought it i totally agree um i think that
it's gonna be just like you said very hard to make
any progress it's it looks like a decent position
for both of them but it's difficult to know how
exactly they are gonna be able to continue the
game now get away that's right so let's keep on
in this match board three maxime lavrov taking on
fyodor michikov and okay i see this knight on d5
i like that but i also see it's under attack and
the material count black is down a pawn but has
the bishop pair and in particular the bishop on
c5 looks pretty nice for black so if the material
stays the way it is white can claim an edge and
push for more but there's that active counter play
for black at least some pressure going forwards
and uh i would prefer white's position but how
big of an advantage would you say white has here
i would say that white um well they are a pawn
up but just like you said black has like hassan
attack has this nice bishop on c5 um wow they're
going for h5 now so i think that this is just a
type of position where white just has to defend
from any immediate any immediate threats like for
instance here h4 is an is an immediate threat i
guess um perhaps so i think that that's more what
they have to do but i think that in the long term
it's going to be fine for white i can't really
see black winning immediately here so so i think
that i think that white is doing pretty well and
i think there's also a lot of resources for white
to defend like this and i can go to f4 now and all
the pieces are sort of together around the king so
i think that white is doing pretty well here i i'm
with you and i'm looking at the clock situation
an extra minute still three minutes for black
that's plenty of time for experienced players but
that extra time could come in handy with the extra
pawn so h5 is a great move as alpha zero type of
let's go h4 you can't take the pawn on h5 because
your knight needs that bishop's defense so h4
is the plan to soften up the g3 square or plant
upon h3 for an attack i think that black with that
move i'm starting to like the chances more i still
prefer white's position let's keep on in this
match the last board we have maria comey gina
with the black pieces and i see the eval bar in
black's favor and it's because these pawns here
are fantastic for black it's even material white
has this connect four pawn chain but the pawns in
the center are mobile whereas white's pawns are
stopped none of them can move on the dark squares
yep none of them can can move and it's just this
just looks very very this just looks very well
to be honest uh these two pawns are going to be
absolutely amazing the f and e pawn especially
in an end game i think that e pawn is going to be
super strong and now they just took on on h5 it
just seems like they're up material right one two
three four five six two three four yeah she's up
one pawn so this just seems just seems very good
it was an understandable mistake h5 was played
because you want to win the f5 punch i don't
want my h-phone i want this f5 pawn because then
e4 is weak but unfortunately h5 comes with the
cost of this rook black takes that very quickly
i will say that black's position while you're
ahead of material it could come under fire if
you're not careful if you allow this capture
on e4 there could be some attack but for
starters you have to deal with the bishop first
this knight can just sit on g5 so black is well
ahead and if you play carefully you should be able
to take this point yeah that knight on g5 is going
to be a very strong night and it's just going to
protect the whole king and white cannot even go
knight f3 to try to exchange it uh because of this
pawn on e4 so that knight on g5 is just a monster
it is indeed and this would be a very good game
for spare to take over spare bank trade union uh
at first i was going to say spare but then i
realized they're kind of playing each other
so i can't just say that and this game looks
very good for black let's keep on going
uh throughout these games i'm just going
to pull one at random at this point
let's go to alina kashlinsky's game where with
the white pieces she is down upon and her king
is under attack so fareed for monsieur with the
black pieces we saw the karakan the bishop now has
a diagonal to work with but all the other pieces
are gone and blacks up a pawn with an attack
yeah this is looking really really really great
um for fi manchia i mean alina is completely
restricted in the sense that her queen cannot
really move anywhere the queen is going to have
to stay on the first rank to prevent the queen
black's queen from going to g1 and checkmate so
this just because of that fact
just looks absolutely amazing for
um or for mancha but also the fact that
you know she she is even a pawn up there
yeah wow queen g5 played protecting the pawn on
g3 and if h6 where's this okay the bishop's under
attacks look at this grand masters do blunder
h6 blunders the piece i'm trying to distract
the queen from g3 but i can't forgive my bishop so
f6 that would potentially weaken the king if the
queen can come to f3 and get some checks in
so you have to be very precise at a moment
like this you don't want to blunder like i just
did and one idea is queen e1 to make sure the
white's queen can't get back on the first ranks
then you can play bishop to d4 i feel like black
should be able to get through it by the way yon
napominshi have to go to that game has won his
individual matchup against anton korboff the final
position was one where he got that rook into c7
he pushed that pawn to e6 that's bad news for the
king on f8 yeah now that just looks super strong
we were talking about it before if corbett was
going to be able to defend um his position but
it seemed like it was not due to the past pawn
or the isolated pawn that corbett lost but it was
due to how great nippo had all of his pieces and
the very weak king that that korboff had and also
you know that pin there so it seemed as if it
was not just due to isolated pawn that's right
and i'm going to go to this game here in the other
match because i'm looking at this end game and now
in august we loved her position earlier but
chelsea monica has found a way out of this
it looks like it's going to be an even trade
this pawn cannot be defended unless you put
your knight on d6 and white will not take that
knight at least not yet the king will come to g3
it should be a level position so that's going
to be presumably of all things hold a draw on
this board i'm going to go to the georg meyer
game where he's still playing this is the most
york meyer position that you could possibly have
white the engines is slightly better york has
under a minute left but he's the bishop pair so
he's going to try to work his magic play a nice
end game here to try to take down his opponent
but it's 94 such a problem for black to deal with
yeah definitely bishop a6 okay so he's trying
to to kick the kick that work away i am very
impressed i mean there's a big rating
difference in this game and i think
that white is playing really well and he's
also up on time so i think that you know
um i mean has been playing super well this game
rexy7 is going back and now we can see that he's
trying to get this repetition of moves he's
trying to get a draw here bye and maybe we're
going to see that because we can see that they're
repeating at this moment so the game might finish
right here if i'm york i'm looking very quickly
other games if even if i go down to five seconds
left i need to make sure my team doesn't need
me to win he's probably keeping out he makes a
draw let's go within this match and let's go to
elena kashlinska that's their board too bishop
on e4 this is under attack maybe you can't play
f6 you drop the pawn on g6 that's not something
you want to do but f5 could be a good idea of
the queen e7 check as soon as he pushes f pawn
your king gets in trouble so you have to be yeah
precise here you have to be very precise i thought
that before it was quite interesting because it
looked as if white almost had no moves like black
had their pieces in such a great position that
it almost seemed like white cannot really move
anything it was almost like a six swank so it's
interesting to see how how the position changed
and how how they got here but yeah this this
still just looks absolutely amazing for for mancha
and i guess that she wants to it's it's different
it's difficult when they already have their
oh in such a great position but queen a1 okay i
was not expecting them but i thought the bishop
was going to move instead and i would put my queen
on e3 and ask you how you're going to beat me and
the evaluation went from minus 9 to now minus 1.3
but that's why engines can be so misleading that
position i don't know what black's best move is
here like this looks like a tough position because
the queen defends the queen attacks you can't
play f5 because of the checks and queening
one looks like a reasonable move but after
queen e3 and queenie two the king feels safer
now play queen g2 queen f3 try to trade the
queens off the board if those queens come off
white is not losing this game or i guess bishop
g2 is just hey my king is tucked on h3 and safe so
somehow alina kashinska she is saving this one at
least for now let's go to some of the other games
where we see okay we were looking earlier where
black was totally winning and black still has a
big advantage but i'm looking at this d-pawn as
a potential problem for black especially as we
approach time trouble all right we're gonna
have to bop around here oh okay though this
king this king's in trouble that's actually a
great move the king is in trouble yes king g4
check right there and if the king goes to h5
you get checkmated immediately so rook at four
king age five you go rook to e4 and that's game
checkmate you can't stop it that's a nice puzzle
that's uh yeah very very cool checkmate yeah she
they're they're going yeah she's going for rook
for check here now so we're gonna see where the
king goes king has to go to g3 and the other she's
just going to keep on checking and then this king
comes into oh well don't drop the pawn you want
to drop the pawn but at some point soon the king
can go to f6 the pawn can't move because e6 is
hanging i just saw quartermaine hannah marie cluck
wins the game by resignation she is up at rook and
you want to know how she's up a rook rook d8
was just played and she took so hannah marie
kleck gets that win for gronkey that's huge and
what a slip because queen f8 looks like white
on the offensive but she played g5 so her king
can escape oh gosh that's a sad turn of events
for pt and grunky must be thrilled yup yup we've
seen some of those and you know they really hurt
those type of those type of blunders but they
happen and especially with little time so let's
go back to the game with helena yeah did you see
that it was like -17 and king h6 was the wrong
move which means that somehow you probably should
play the queen here and g5 g4 and go for some
checkmate but it's not it's easier said than done
maybe g5 right away is the way to go and that's
probably it but it's hard to play with g5 with
30 seconds in your clock you worry about your
your own king and now it's back to even so
for that one moment there black hat it again
and eric meyer has made a draw so hannah marie
kleck wins the game that means it's tie uh two to
one so the worst that gronke can do is i think the
worst they can do is tie but unless i'm mistaken
because oh they won wait i'm now very
confused by this inaugural is still playing so
we'll see how that one finished out but
right now white on this board is doing okay
all the games are finishing the same time we
have too much to deal with look at this game
between kadatsky and kretov opposite colored
bishops we saw a player in the previous match
unfortunately slip and allow the pawn to promote
this time neither player allowing that at least
for now no they're not gonna make the same
mistake again that's a good thing when you make
one mistake you start thinking uh more about like
really preventing that from happening again so i'm
sure that they're not gonna allow any pawn from
promoting here and spare is up three nothing so
uh it looks like this game no matter
who ends up victorious if anybody it's
not going to make a difference for the match
spare will move on being spare bank trading
let's go back to the other match because
that of course has much more at stake
oh sorry i clicked on the wrong game i was going
here but black did win that game we were looking
earlier so fareed for matcha is still trying to
win he needs to win this game with black and i
would even consider queen f4 check right now i'm
not sure if that end game holds but it's a move to
consider to trade the queens off because obstacle
bishop end games notorious for being drawn
this is going to become a difficult game to
play though i think for both players and black
is trying to like is trying to find that big
advantage and finding a way to convert this
to a win and for white is going to be really
difficult to play because the king is unsafe
but now we can see that white has found a way
to check the black king and now it seems almost
as if for manchester wants to exchange those
query but she should take that queen her team
is up two to one if i'm not mistaken i see that i
should definitely take that queen in agares drew
georg meyer drew and um how do we collect one she
just needs to draw but she might not know that
because she's in the middle of a time scramble
but she just needs to draw trade queens if you can
yeah change queens and it's just
immediately a draw with this take
she's playing like not for a witness maybe she
thinks this is the easiest way to hold but trading
queens ensures that she makes a draw and her team
moves on and it looks like we'll get a repetition
so she gets away with decision not to trade queens
if the repetition is don't get a repetition wow
but it seems as if yeah there we go there
was nothing that black could do to escape so
alina kashlinska she did not win her game haunted
me cluck did win for gronkey they went two and a
half one and a half but she might be the hero by
if you just look at the scorecard and say well the
player who won is the hero alina kashinsky
was completely busted according to the engine
but it was much more difficult
than you know met the eye it's like
to find that wind where is it we
were looking there was no clear way
but there was at that one moment i don't even know
what move it is this game finished at 92 moves
somewhere around these parts maybe it was even
actually earlier than this gotta find this moment
where the king was going back up in h3 and h2
i guess g5 that's the move there we have it
giving up your h5 pawn because g3 is checkmate
the bishop and the queen line up on the square
if you don't do anything g4 check will win and if
you trade and say okay i can't allow g4 that's too
scary let me move my king back a move like h4
should be good but actually g4 is even stronger
because your queen has to move and your queen
cannot stay in line with the g3 pawn hard to
see this with 30 seconds though very difficult to
see it especially because g5 really does change
the whole dynamic of the position and whenever
you move a pawn in pretty much any position
it really does change how how it really does
change the whole position the dynamic of it so
it's really hard to see that with 30 seconds
even though it was a very good tactical move and
yeah i mean i'm sure that i'm sure
that perhaps you'll be a bit upset
if not finding it but that's just that's
just how it is sometimes it's little time
yeah and you know he he had a good game he was
playing well with the black pieces and queen b7
check right that's why you don't play move like
g5 you don't want this kid to get checked too much
but that's only one check and the king can escape
on a dark square and that's the end of your checks
and on the other side i'm going to check and go
for a checkmate so yeah very difficult to analyze
this though with the little time and to realize
that there's no checks left in that position but
yes because the fear is if you make this pawn
push immediately becomes a draw and on the other
hand by the moves that he was playing with the
black pieces he was trying to keep the momentum
saying okay i'm going to keep this position the
status quo is good enough for me because i will
be able to make progress later whereas if i allow
an immediate perpetual check or some kind of queen
trade then i have no chances but ultimately it
was a missed opportunity pt does not win their
match it's not on international master mantra
here it's a team effort and pt they just barely
made it to the semi-finals unfortunately they're
barely eliminated in this round so we know our
final two teams we have our final two teams
this game by the way ended in the draw just for
reminding everyone it was a repetition our
final two we have gronke bank and spare so
as you look at this we know that georg
meyer tops the line for gronka bank
yon napaneshi for spare so strong grandmasters
on board one i mean strong as an understatement
but exceptional grandmasters on board one and
then iams on board two the lowest board is still
well near 2300 anna what do we expect i think that
anything can happen here it's going to be such a
close match and it's going to be so exciting
to follow this final i really cannot wait
um it's going to be super exciting as well to
follow this george meyer and this versus nipple
game it's going to be really really really amazing
to follow such a high level chess game george just
drew versus nippo one so perhaps nipple is feeling
a bit more more confident but once again anything
can happen here and they're both amazing rapid
and blitz players and if you're yon you just beat
anton korbov one of the world's top players you're
feeling good like you said and it's reminding
everybody there will be two games so you you
play your first match then there's a rubber match
oh actually that's not a rubber match but there's
a second match where it's eight games total so
unlike the previous rounds where we've been best
out of four it's best out of eight your team
needs to score four and a half points throughout
the two rounds to win the match so we are going
to take a break but before we do just to remind
everybody if you can please click that panel do
donate if you're able this event is to raise
awareness to raise money for charity and for
some great causes and for the for fide they are
trying to do more for players with disabilities
for some of the elder players for the veterans and
for chess and education so it's very important if
you can we have received many generous donations
to this point thank you so much for this and we
will be back shortly with more coverage of
the fide world corporate chess championship
do
welcome back everybody to the feed a world
corporate chess championships this is the final we
have two teams remaining we will see action begin
at 10 minutes past the hour we want to remind
everybody of what the format is now that we have
reached the final it's a bit different than the
quarters and the semis because the players will
play two matches you get the white color and the
black color against the same opponent and if it is
a four to four tie we will go to a tie break blitz
match three minutes plus two second increment
anna what if the final determined by armageddon
that would be for us absolutely amazing for us
commentators and for everybody else watching that
would be absolutely amazing but for the players i
think that would be very stressful because as we
said before our regents are stressful enough by by
themselves but at armageddon in a team it's a lot
more stressful because there's so much pressure
and yeah i think i think that we would feel better
about it than them that's true we enjoy it it's
fun for us as commentators but as players it's
nerve-wracking and let's remind everyone what
is at stake because it is a chess competition
glory playing better chess sure but there are
prizes so the winning team is declared the fide
online world corporate chess champion i think
that much is fairly straightforward and the first
four teams in the rankings secure forces each
to participate in a simul against the winner
of the candidates we do not know who the winner
of the kens is that tournament will resume in
april and that could be maxine vashi lagrav or jan
napomnishi who's taking part in this they're the
co-leaders or it could be fabiano caruana nishkiri
etc and four players from each of the highest
ranked teams who did not qualify for the playoff
stage will be able to play against juwon june
that's a really exciting experience anna very very
exciting i think that all of these prizes are are
super exciting especially for the people in their
corporations that uh perhaps you know haven't had
the opportunity to meet all of these top elite
players it would be a really cool experience
that's just a lot of players are
thankful just to be taking part
and you know the last part of this is of course
for the charity and that's a big component of this
there's chess playing everyone in the event loves
chess that's why they're taking part in this
but you see the team that raised the most money
will be invited to the world championship match
held later in 2021 that will be between magnus
carlson and the aforementioned winner of the feed
a cannons tournament so you have three nights vip
tickets that will be a fantastic experience and
there are many players enjoying this competition
not just the players who are left remaining and
we have a tweet showing appreciation and it is
from vanessa jetvah whose game we're analyzing
in detail yesterday because he played a great
one 1300 raiden was playing in someone who was
2100 plus and actually had a great position over
playing out playing i should say his opponent and
you see the tweet here best game i played till
date in my chess career what a moment to see my
game getting featured on an official live stream
of this elite event can't express how it feels to
outplay a professional title player with a much
higher rate than you thank you well thank you
we're glad you participated it's a very nice to
see that you enjoyed your experience it is the
first feed a world corporate championship
held online i presume it will not be the
last let's hope it's not and we like everyone's
participation and we have just two minutes before
the round begins i wanted to talk about this end
game and when you're calculating this late stage
of the game don't have much time if you're black
how do you determine just on like a conceptual
level whether to trade rooks and promote your pawn
and calculate the ensuing king and pawn in game
it's it's a very difficult thing to do especially
like you said with the with the little time um
i would say that i mean obviously it depends on
on like the king's position so in this position
the king on on g1 is is holding this f1 square so
the pawn f2 could could promote very soon but then
at the same time you can see that the king that
is going to f7 is going to be able to walk all
the way to d7 and protect c7 and then that king is
going to be after after the bishop sacks itself or
it has to take the pawn and c7
yeah you can put out the moves
so to make it a bit more clear then you
sort of have to calculate this position
and where the king will be closer to taking
that a pawn then the black king will be able to
either protect the pawn or take the a4 pawn so
i think that in this position you sort of have
to calculate if that king and pawning game is
going to be winning and that is something that
um it's a bit different with an apon because um
there are all of these style meeting ideas okay
we're gonna get that we're gonna get the game
started yep too bad we were talking i yo that's
my fault didn't uh bring it up in time was reading
the tweet but uh the games are beginning we don't
want to miss the action we can talk about the
rest of the end game later george meyer starts
with the white pieces against ian napoli we
see knight f3 and c4 an english opening system
by georg we will have our eyes on all four games
and it's the first of two matches everybody so uh
only four boards we know exactly who's playing
gronke against spare and this is the heavyweight
matchup on board one but equally important
are some of these other games so uh it's still
very early on i don't think we need to hop around
just yet but anna i always like these bishops on
g2 i just i'm a big fan of the enchanter i'm a big
fan of the fiance as well as long as there's not
a big massive pawns blocking the bishop in the
center but in this position that's not the case
the bishop on g2 has the full diagonal and it's
a it's a very active piece so i definitely prefer
that bishop on g2 over the bishop on d7 well
the bishop on d7 could at some point exchange
itself for that bishop but that's another story no
that's irrelevant it's definitely relevant detail
you often want to trade off this powerful bishop
and the bishop came to d7 to protect the knight
on c6 to protect the knight c6 no you're not
going to take that but there are moments where
you do take if black is forced to take with the
pawn to shatter the structure on the queen side
but look at yon i mean f6 you're creating a pawn
chain here this knight can come to e6 potentially
he can castle king side i do like his bishop
white plays f4 to strike in the center and you
know george's position to my eyes is favorable
but young playing quickly and confidently
and uh it's going to be a messy game it's going
to be an amazing game to follow i'm so excited
about this game and it's really i mean these are
just two top top players it's going to be such a
high quality chess game and i'm super excited
to see what they bring to the table and strong
players on all four boards less excitement if
i bring up this game between elena kashlinskaya
and alexander kadetsky because the queens are off
the board nothing major has happened except for
the queen trade and the move a6 played by elena
allowing this bishop to take the knight because
those double pawns won't be here for very long
once black takes in the center so the bishop pair
we hear about that all the time isn't that just a
good thing for black to have the bishop here yes
it is but even though the pawns will not remain
doubled they could be attacked and oftentimes
white wants to put a knight on b3 and try to take
over these dark squares on the king side the pond
on a6 and c6 leave squares here available for
white to try and take advantage of yeah exactly
so well just like i said even though bishop pairs
we hear about them all the time and they are great
um i mean it also like kind of depends on the
position and if the bishop pair if the bishops
are going to be good in a certain position so
i don't know would you say that the bishop pair
is strong in this position robert for black i
would say white's position because the lead in
development and that's part of it and this bishop
on the light squares that's the problematic piece
if this this may be a bit uh hard to recognize for
many but if black has to trade these pieces for
these pieces so the bishop and knight for white
the dark square bishop and the knight for black
this light square bishop is very bad against
the knight because of the dark square holes on
the queen side so this is what you need to think
about as you grow as chess players what pieces
do we want traded and how can i take advantage of
some of my opponent's weaknesses having a knight
against a bishop that knight can go from color
to color and a knight on a dark square cannot be
attacked by a light square bishop exactly and
those are the advantages and disadvantages of
of uh of having a bishop player or you know having
knights instead so it all depends on the exact
position that's right and well this position still
early players are thinking let's move on to board
four for a second maria comey ajino with the white
pieces inna agrest and solid thus far we started
in a spanish that looks sort of like an italian
because uh not to in piece of interest this bishop
is well not two no pieces have been traded the
bishop's on the diagonal towards the enemy king
this knight can come to g3 or e3 as it happens in
the italian very often so anna are we going to see
a capture next move for white or are we gonna have
to wait a few more four pieces are getting traded
you know it's pretty uncommon that 13 moves
go and there's been no trade whatsoever
but um yeah i'm i'm not sure if if i don't think
that black is one is going to want to trade on
a4 because when black trades on a4 what happens
then is that the a file gets open for the work
and that a6 pawn could be in some trouble at
some point although what is also true is that
the b file becomes open so there are there
are goods and bats but i don't really think
that they're going to take yet i think they
would rather reinforce that pawn on b5 and
that's what inagurus is doing by going c6 that's
right and white can't take on b5 at any moment
it's not like black is going to take on a4 as you
were saying so that's why instead of capturing we
see d4 well now other pawns can be captured but
does white want to take on e5 does black want to
take on d4 these are difficult questions to answer
at first glance taking on d4 allows white to get
these strong pawns and you don't have a pawn on
the e5 blocking so essentially you give white
two pawns in the center to your one that typically
is an advantage for the side with the two because
those pawns can push and pawns in the center
restrict pieces very well so i don't think that
you know we'll be taking on d4s trying to figure
out another way even though e64 is not a blunder
it's not that big of a deal it just becomes
a difficult strategic battle after that
maybe something that black would want to
do is to go c5 to just uh to just try to
get a little bit more control of the centers
that this two versus one thing doesn't happen
i like the idea of c5 for sure she plays queen
e7 first and she's just keeping the status quo i
would jump my knight to g3 try to land that knight
on f5 because even if it's captured if i take with
the e pawn my rook wins the battle against your
queen down the e line so knight g3 standard move
regardless the position but i think it's has more
punch right now with the follow up being knight f5
i think that white station is good let's move
on to the one game we haven't checked out yet
between hannah marie kleck the sole victor
for gronka bank in the previous round in the
semifinals she takes on maxine lavrov and and
i have to admit i really like white's position
this was the four nights game and the bishop on
d3 looks really good staring at the h7 square
now that we're trading off this knight on f6 yep
that knight on f6 is typically the big defender
uh on on that on this h7 checkmate and we
can see that that bishop on the three is
pointing right at h7 and probably is going
to be joined by the queen very soon as well
and while the asia here becomes as well that
if g6 is ever played well then the h6 pawn
is going to become very weak and that black's
pieces seem to be a little bit uncoordinated
to defend on the king side so for instance rook on
b4 although it is the it is attacking on c4 it's
also not really helping out on the defense and i
think that soon black's pieces are going to have
to defend that's absolutely correct and this pawn
d5 is under attack because the queen helps out
so white is threatened to win a pawn but more
importantly the attack because you could take
on c4 thinking wait i can win your pawn and after
pawn takes oh let me take with that bishop here
and you're going to see the eval bar yep i knew
that was coming because this is a blunder and the
reason why is look at this situation piecer in a
row looks defended but i can even make a move like
queen to h4 potentially a queen to c5 type of move
and the reason why queen c5 can be played is there
are so many pieces under attack including this
rook on fa just to show you a sample variation
if you go queen b6 i have bishop h7 check
as a possibility your king can take and the
queen takes this rook here white can steal some
material with an attack to boot yeah very nice
line so because we have to work on before being
unprotected could become a weakness for black
i also think that quite soon we're going to be
seeing a rick lift perhaps for white uh those
rooks i think are gonna start getting into the
game yes rookie four rookie three type of moves
i would take back here i think you should probably
deal with the pawn first although i was talking
about the pin rookie four is a possibility because
this rook is hanging queen h4 or queen g4 one of
these type of moves is possible trying to pin this
pawn but queen see if i played going for the check
going for the check yes and the question then
becomes can black just take on d3 and say
all right we're giving an exchange we're
sacrificing an exchange but that pawn on
d3 could become strong and this is our best
shot basically yeah it actually doesn't hate it
this advantage is for white but we knew that
going in at least that gives good compensation
as the bishop will stay protecting it i think
that it's going to be relatively easy game for
white not to win but just to play going forward
you can blockade the pawn on a dark square bring
your other rook maybe into e7 so white has the
upper hand but it will not be an easy conversion
so uh the queen's e5 is a very good move i'm
just looking at the other games to make sure
we're not missing anything substantial the game's
still going on some of them closed positions
i'm going to quickly hop to this game
we'll come right back i see a lot of trades
so white has the rooks on the e file very good
rooks but bad pawns so it's the evil bars is
black is slightly better i look at this think
that white has a pretty good initiative going on
whose position would you take whites or black
i would take whites from just the first glance
and because it seems that white just has so
active pieces but i guess that the reason why
they feel like black is a bit better do you
think it's because of white's pawn structure
it must be but i think it's easier to blunder as
black rook c7 falls into knight a6 you can't kick
my knight out of the c5 square my rook's on the
e file hitting the c6 pawn i think white's in no
danger whatsoever right now i would prefer the
position and if we trade the rooks this is high
level but if you can visualize say these rooks are
gone all four rooks there could be an outside past
pawn situation that i can throw through so that's
later in the game i want to go back to this game
because the tactical moment was avoided rook b8
played the very safe move defending this rook
so bishop h7 doesn't work pawn takes c4 i still
prefer white's position thanks to this bishop
the bishop on e6 is not nearly as strong but
perhaps black is one move away just one from
surviving this initiative maybe it could be
rook to d8 or rook to e8 one of these rooks here
yeah very close but perhaps they perhaps they
are they are close enough to able to survive this
so yeah it seems like it looked better
before than what we have right now
but as you said i think that white is a little
bit better as well because of this bishop and
perhaps because you know i don't know if the rick
goes to d8 for instance and we see something like
queen f5 i guess that idea is then just to
go g6 right and that's the way of defending
you were right to point out when the queen is on
h5 g6 was not possible but you wait till the queen
goes away now the pawn is not under attack so
it looks like you can parry the immediate threat
and i will just say at this moment here it felt
like the tactical ideas were working better than
keeping the material equal so i would have
gone for pawn takes c4 i didn't calculate it
all through but it looked like a position where
black would have had a difficult time trying to
stave off all the threats but queen f4 played that
gives up the c6 pawn it also gives up the a7 pawn
so maybe it's the right choice henry collects says
all right i kept the tension alive i didn't give
up material and now she can scoop off either pawn
i would take on a7 i like that pawn to capture
yeah it feels like the c6 pawn is always
going to be a weakness anyways and also if you
if you take the c6 pawn you're opening up
the sea fall which could perhaps lead to rick
putting some pressure on the c4 pond so it seems
like it's uh just very natural to take the a7 pawn
and she goes for the rook left look at that you
you mentioned the rook left early [ __ ] pawns
i'm not going for the pawns i'm going for the king
and this pawn isn't going anywhere this pawn won't
be captured next because the bishop will go to
b7 but that a7 pawn is a problem and rook g4
looks pretty scary too yeah so so she's going
for the king attack and for the work lift but
i think that at some point taking those
pawns has to be really good as well
agreed and let's go to the top board i'll keep
an eye on this one between garrick meyer and
young napoli because in that game i just see
way too many pieces to know what's going on
all four minor pieces both sides have those
six pawns each i thought that there were more
pawns because i saw these bishops and i assumed
one of them was a pawn but no those are bishops
the bishop on g3 i think we can agree not of
exactly a very powerful bishop the bishop on g2
full length and diagonal but empty space and one
of the main questions i have is can white at some
point play e4 well that palm was just taken
didn't even see that pawn was hanging i wasn't
i was looking at the center and all the pieces
jan takes the pawn but the engine didn't love it
you know robert maybe now that the queen is gone
maybe now that now e4 could be an idea that's what
you were mentioning and perhaps you can just go
e for now um okay are you going for rick a1 first
she put some pressure on a7 as well you know
the main drawback of e4 is that the d4 square
but there's no knight d4 because after knight
takes d4 our queens stare at each other yours
is not defended and my knight can recapture
on c2 if you take my queen so that's probably
part of the reason why e4 was available there
and instead york puts the rook on a6 that rook
darts over the queen side cements the pawn in
place attacks this knight on e6 keep and the queen
tied down and i don't see a plan for black that's
part of the problem bishop f7 what is this i've
never seen a configuration like this before you
know very interesting george just offered a draw
right before well right after rook a6 and and
iron by going bishop f7 declined that draw
i don't know who thinks they're better maybe
both sides just think it's interesting there is a
second uh match right so even if you lose the game
now your team gets to come back by the way alina
keschlinska and alexander kudaski have drawn their
game on board two we thought that was pretty level
so knight d6 played by george the c5 pawn is
now under attack the bishop is under attack
pressure on f5 but then again the evaluation
bar says that wasn't the best move like you
had something better but why is that not a good
move just the calm bishop g8 look at that bit i
mean this whole configuration of pieces is just
so interesting how they're all kind of together
on the king side almost no pieces on on the
queen side i don't i haven't seen something
like this to be honest no and what the way i would
define this position is headache inducing because
i don't know what to do as there's too many pieces
i want to trade something i i feel like i need to
be quick here if i'm white and york says i'm
not going to be quick on h3 i don't know the
exact purpose of that move it does give the king
a square off the back rank but this bishop on g3
remains a problem so i think that yon if he's
careful he can have the upper hand here but for
now it's too crowded the board so i'm going to go
to inna aggressive scheme she's playing on board
four so let's go there she's taking on maria comey
gina and speaking of rook lifts if you take on e3
or nazi gun b6 there could be a rook lift at some
point but that look at that here we go rook a7
this rook can go to d6 to take the d file whose
rooks are going to be better in this game anna
that is a great question i don't really see how
the rooks on the a file could immediately cause
any problem um i mean they they are great on
the a file or they look great on the a file
but i'm not really sure where they're going to
be honest right the f7 pawn you can't attack
it because this pawn c4 is such a annoying piece
your bishop on c2 doesn't look very good and one
rook on d8 the other come to d6 this bishop
can develop out here and this knight on h4
is it happy here it wanted to go to f5 but if it
does black can just snap it off the board so queen
e2 play to get the queen save and i think rook
to d6 makes sense try to land their work on d2
yep i think that rick detrow is a much bigger
threat than any brook in the a fell could create
anytime soon but okay she's going queen c5 instead
um she's going queen c5 instead and that sets up
rook to d6 and so as they're blocking the queen in
this queen is already active on c5 it attacks that
rook on a7 so i think white has to be careful here
maria she is up over a minute on the clock that's
good news for for her but inna is starting to
seize the initiative her pieces are getting active
rook a5 puts pressure on this b-pawn that b-pawn's
very well defended not a big deal i think you can
still slide the rook to d6 and try to play for
more so let's uh move on quickly to the game that
we were looking at in detail how to make clock
i saw this at the corner of my eye which is why
i had to go here look at this position look at the
eval bar you say wait why is it so good isn't this
just the position where it's even material after
queen takes c6 was just played where's that bishop
going right bishop is cannot really go anywhere
because if bishop c8 the rook on a8 is hanging
the rook on a8 is hanging so the bishop can't go
to see it to save it the bishop's under attack
that leaves him like queen a5 queen d2 played
to attack the rook and the bishop on d3 but here
comes this rook here comes the second rook and
rooks on the seventh rank are just devastating
they absolutely are they're going to be completely
devastating so many rook lifts we've seen today
robert okay maybe not a rook lift yet but the
potential of seeing them rook f7 sacrificing
for checkmate i think that's the way to go here
just take on f7 remove the defender of the g6 pawn
and i don't think that black can really survive i
guess black will sacrifice the q or actually made
it to rook f7 this queen takes d3 so i should be a
little more careful with that wow this is a little
more complicated than thought so maybe just rookie
three that's rook left second rook left oh maybe
there was an opportunity after queen 63 i don't
know if you could go queen e7 because then that
seventh rank was really really really vulnerable
but i'm not sure perhaps there was a way of
doing that the end engine justifies it plus six
even though you're down a piece for a couple pawns
so if rook takes f7 had to be the move i kind
of talked myself out of it but rook b won rookie
eight and all of a sudden black's trying to fend
off the attack and attack the queen instead but
queen d5 puts more pressure and there's pressure
in all directions this rook on eight still under
attack the pawn f7 is threatened no this queen
d5 quizzes six also good same ideas before yeah
and now my team i mean he's getting into very very
very uh low very low time he has 45 seconds left
so he's gotta have to play fast it really
feels like hannah just has just has the very
big advantage both with the position but also with
the time so it's probably it's probably gonna be
it's probably gonna be a i don't know can we say
that it can be it's gonna be a win here can we say
that already i'm scared of saying that because i
feel like i'm going to jinx it but yeah i think
we can say that and especially right now bishop
takes g6 the queen comes over this king is has no
defenders so a nice game here by henry kleck she
was the reason grunky moved on by winning her game
her opponent dropped a rook unexpectedly but if
she wins this she's showing that hey i'm here and
i'm ready to help our team to the championship and
if she plays bishop takes g6 i think the game will
and there it is the game will be over in just
a few moves rook f8 doesn't even help you can
still take on f7 because this rook on a that's
been a problematic piece this whole way through
yeah it definitely has and we're finally seeing
isaac and yeah ricky won now but the king can just
just escape to h2 there's not really any big issue
there and now everything's hanging the bishop on
a6 the rook on a the pawn f7 and if you take on g6
i can even just take back and meet you just okay
rook g3 is probably good g3 is also good there are
no bad moves in this position no no absolutely not
i see here that um yeah the brick is hanging i
mean everything is hanging this is just one of
those type of positions and you only have six five
seconds left yeah so we have to go to speaking of
five seconds after this game concludes or maybe
right now gotta go to george meyer against yon
apameshi because that game that we know this one's
going to be over in white's favor this game barely
getting that rook back to defend the last rank
york has eight seconds and he's unfortunately down
a pawn so it looks like the other game did just
conclude in white's favor and now you're trying
desperately to hold here he's down the pawn his
king is weak his 9.5 seconds anna can you do it
doesn't look like it i don't think so i think this
is looking very very tough i mean he's a great
blitz player but seven seconds it's extremely
hard and that b-pawn is just pushing although now
well rick b6 but i don't know if you can even go
b2 yeah exactly very beautiful move what a way to
try to finish this game if that queen was captured
the rook would take back and it would have been
supporting the queening square so now whoa whoa
both players missing things you saw that eval bar
drop like crazy and that must mean oh my gosh
could have taken on b2 the bishop was pinned
oh wow missed the chance there to take the pawn
and now rook b8 happens and you're in a losing
position and you're resigning yeah wow just to
show that everybody what a sequence here b2 if
you take the queen the rook replaces it can't
stop me from promoting the best you sacrifice
your queen for the new queen and after what was
played uh b2 uh when the queen went to f5 here
queen c7 this pawn could be captured the bishop
is pinned so missed opportunity let's go to the
final game that's still going the score is one and
a half one and a half and this position oh my gosh
it's wow final game with one and a half one and a
half that's very exciting all stakes are on this
game and you know they will no matter what get
a second match but you're right having the lead
taking control of the match going to the second
second one this looks promising for white at this
point but don't take this pawn too soon there's
g5 check which would be a fork maybe e5 i would
try to play for e5 there good yeah now the knight
is stopping any e5 type of move but she had g5
i understand with not that much time playing any
kind of pawn move can be worrisome but look at the
eval bar turning in black's favor all of a sudden
maybe this rook will slide to a6 and use the open
file absolutely absolutely they're both just
trying to get there and now g5 the h3 pawn that
was hanging and h3 pawn is hanging she doesn't
have much time though rook takes but h3 is still
hanging and you don't want to drop that pawn too
no she's defending it but that's not a good move
and you don't want it you had to defend it but
it's not a move you want to play and this rook
is in rook g1 rook g3 anybody bring that rook
up rook do you want now she's playing workout
she needs to find rook she won she's not finding
ricky one are they going to go back oh my gosh
that's a huge shame for inaugura she actually had
the upper hand here and she didn't have much time
and you get nervous you're playing for your
team but when this rook comes to g1 and to
g3 down goes h3 attacks the pawn c3 and black is
probably already winning objectively at this point
you see the evaluation showing in black's favor
and i can't really blame her she doesn't want to
lose the game that would be the worst thing she
played well with the black pieces in the next
set of games she gets the white pieces so
maybe just drawing with black you know as
a result for the team that's a good thing two
to two anna we could not have a closer match
it's so close and now i can actually say that all
stakes are gonna be on this very last match it's
going to be so exciting to follow all of these
games and i mean i really really can't wait
yes and i'm just trying to get confirmation
on when the next round is to remind you all to
stay put don't go anywhere it's two to two we not
we're not getting into blitz just yet we will have
another set of these rapid time control uh games
and the next one will be in 15 minutes at 5-0 50
past the hour so 10 minutes before the next hour
that will be when the next games take place which
means we are going to go on a short break but
before we do just a reminder that this event is
about raising awareness raising money for great
initiatives for players with disabilities for
veteran chess players and for chess and education
so if you can please do show your support your
generosity is appreciated so many of you have
been taking part and give your donations it is
seriously thank you from the bottom of my
heart but for now and i will take a break
when we return we'll come back for the final match
of the final of the fide world corporate chess
championship
do
so
welcome back everybody to the fide world
corporate championship this is the finals anna
we had a break we were relaxing for a little do
you think the players could relax at all i think
that they're nervous this finished up in two two
so everything is set for this very last match and
this match is going to decide who the winner of
the feed online world corporate chess championship
is so it's going to be a very exciting match
and i'm really looking forward to it what would
you have done if you have a break between matches
would you prepare it all or would you just try to
erase chest from your mind for a few minutes take
a breath of fresh air just like go to the window
maybe you know just eat something how do you
approach this preparation or relaxation i would
say relaxation i mean i know that i get nervous
so i would probably have ended up preparing
something anyway sort of like with an exam you
just you know that you should not be studying
five minutes before the test when you're walking
into a room but you end up doing it anyway but i
think that really the best thing is just to relax
take something to eat maybe bring a glass of water
get some air whatever it is that makes you relax
because then that that will really that'll really
just set you in the mood for the game i think for
sure and we'll remind everybody of how we got here
which teams remaining it is gronky bank taking
on spare in the finals you see half half because
they split the first match uh it's two to two
of the four games gronkey defeated onowak and
also pt in that oh that was a tough finish
for pt and on the other side of things spare
defeats erg and then beats spare bank trade
union which was led by anton korbov another
super grand master so spare with yon upanishi
on the top board gromke garg meyer but honestly
this has been about some of the other boards and
that's what happens in team events it's not just
the super grand master at the top no hannah
marie kleck has had a great showing she won
in the semifinals she just won the first game
of the finals so she's been the mvp for gronkey
absolutely absolutely so really you cannot just
look at one board and decide from that board you
know who's the strongest player that's the team
that's gonna win no this is a team championship
and it's all about the four boards so robert
do you have do you have any prediction or sort
of do do do you know who do you who you think
that's gonna win or how are you feeling about
this last match yeah i have a prediction for you
chess is going to be played that's my prediction
and we see the gronky team on screen here and
for those of you wondering every single team
gets one free agent and grandmaster georg meyer
the number one player for this team he works at
grunke so he is not the free agent a lot of the
teams with grandmasters that's the free agent but
no here it's elina kaslinskaya who was brought in
at the rating 2494 you're only allowed one player
over 2500 so they chose her at 24.94 she's very
experienced very well prepared super strong is
a great person as well so i think she's proven
to be a fantastic addition to this team and for
georg and the crew one match four games remain
and the games are starting yon napomshi gets the
white pieces against george meyer he did
beat york he's beaten ants on corbett
before that so he has proven that he is an elite
player and he's doing the best he can for spare
absolutely we're seeing here the game's starting
they've switched the board so now ayan is playing
with the white pieces so we're gonna see some new
some new openings in new repertoires but i feel
like we've seen a lot of bishops on you on g2 this
uh this championship or at least today feels like
almost every bishop has gone to g2 and there'd be
a lot of fianchettos so we're seeing another one
in this game with g3 bishop g2 yeah this bishop
came to g2 the long diagonal the bishop on c8
will not be quite as strong and the queens
are traded that does not mean it's just equal
or boring blacks can have a tough time
finishing development bishop comes to g2
it attacks his pawn on b7 and black and castle
queenside but sometimes you castle queenside
without queens in the board and there still
is a potential attack white has an extra pawn
on the queen side so after bishop g2 you can
think about a4 pushing some pawns of the board
and if the king goes to c8 perhaps the black
king will find safety but it won't be that easy
nope it won't be that easy and that's a really
good point that you're making that you know
white has one extra pawn on the queen side
so sometimes you can sort of think about that
for in games for instance a lot of times when that
when the king is is castling on the king's side
that x and the king is really far away from the
queen side that extra pawn on the queen side could
really make a difference when entering an end game
we can see now that the king has castle queen side
oh that's a good point and an illustration
of that as those pawn scene start pushing
and you would say black shut up the advantage i
didn't mean to take the pawn black should have
an advantage because of the pawn on e6 that's upon
the center but the problem is creating a pass pawn
for black is much more difficult in these end
games because the king is closer to the center
you want to keep the king close to center of
the end game so a4 is played by young he also
has ideas of knight b5 bishop f4 and if you're not
careful for gear you could find your king falling
victim to an attack so let's keep on going let's
go to board two alina kashlinskaya is taking on
graffiti master alexander kadatsky and well
she is just locked into the screen here that's
what happens when you're playing chess at first
you're oh this is the best camera angle for me
you forget that you're on camera because you're
so focused on the board on the play and anna
we have another fianchetto but we have matching
fianchettos and opposite the board so who's king
is gonna be under attack my opinion looks
like white has the safe for the two kings
but what do you think i think that i i
think i agree with you i kind of feel like
white's attack on the black king could be could
be could be quite quick like just you know just
just going something like i know f3 g4 h4 all of
that is happening very quickly and i can't really
see exactly how black is going to attack the white
king yet because something like i mean b5 b4 would
not really leech anything so i guess then b5 a5
but then the b5 pawn is going to be hanging so
it seems like it's going to take quite a
long time for black to attack the white king
you just illustrate that very well and the hero is
the f3 pawn because there are more pawns for white
we're trying to attack black doesn't have a pawn
on c6 so that you can then play a5 so this pawn on
f3 defends the center and also helps these pawns
go forward so black's quote unquote attack not
really picking up steam anytime soon and i think
this can be extremely dangerous and alina also
is well ahead in the clock nearly two minutes
at this point and her plan to push forward
as you said more straightforward and it's not
going to be simple as let's go get a checkmate
because i push my pawns up black can defend
it just feels easier to play at this point for
alina yeah i totally agree i totally agree so it's
gonna be exciting to see what happens in this game
we will keep an eye on it let's
go to the board three keep on
going down the line up we have hannah marie kleck
with the black pieces so far winning her games for
grand quebec and you have maxine lavrov with the
white his international master and look at this
position this knight on d4 pawn and d5 say let me
take advantage of the c6 square but black often
can say i'll put my bishop on d7 or i'll put my
bishop on b7 to attack your pawn at some point and
this pawn on d5 can actually be over extended so
i think white wants to play f4 to get the knight
into c6 but what he's quickly recognizing is that
after f4 while that looks good i'm attacking the
knight black can throw in in a shot against the
queen your queen has only one safe square to go to
queen of d2 and now my knight comes in with tempo
so you don't get knight c6 winning a piece that's
what you want is if this knight goes to d7 you get
knight c6 that ends the game in white's favor but
because you throw on bishop to g4 you can play
knight c4 and then you get some time to regroup
yep very very good point that bishop g4 was a very
nice move but it was not played by hannah instead
she played c5 in this position what a move c5
would never even consider it she knows he's just
giving a pun but it's filling the square that's
her idea she she's filling the square so the
knight can't go here and i guess her claim anna is
she'll get that pawn back later and it's justified
according to the engine she is better according
to the computer very cool move that really i mean
yeah i did not think about that move at all but
yeah wow that's that's that's such a cool moose
i guess that now now maybe she can go for the
same idea as you said before with bishop g4 just
to you know develop her pieces immediately and get
that rick to c8 or queen to c7 to attack that pawn
she's going for 94 instead but oh now the
evaluation that's starting to go up and up for
white the extra pawn i guess is going to feel safe
if this knight can land on d5 black's position is
in trouble so i would look for that i know that if
this queen lands on h4 for black all of a sudden
there's some counter play so maybe like a d5
bishop c5 queen h4 that's the kind of quick moves
you need for black in a position like this where
you're down material yep but it might take a while
that's uh that station i'm not really sure where
this knight is going now if let's say for instance
h3 is the knight then just to go the idea just to
go back to f6 oh now you can't but okay queen b6
this makes sense if you get a turn you can pile up
on this knight on d4 so h3 while it may try to win
this on g4 your knight on d4 is also falling
victim to an attack so actually it was much
trickier because knight c3 was the move i said and
yet bishop f6 played him the eval bar goes down
so i don't know what white possibly missed there
nicely look like such a normal move but that's
how tricky chess can be where yeah if you have the
engine as your assistant you can play all the best
moves without it it's a complicated game of course
but we're trying to work through the complications
and help you out but queen b6 now the threat there
also could be an idea of bishop takes and queen h4
if you're not careful hitting the h2 pawn and the
rook on e1 so if you play some careless movie a3
and we get some situation like this queen h4 let
me drop the queen there hits the rook and hits
the pawn so white is the one who suddenly needs to
be careful yeah now you have to be very careful in
these type of situations there are many tactics
and yeah some ideas like like uh like queen b6
could also be perhaps played but she's going for
h3 now all right he's going for h3 now max him i
think you have to play queen b you're not playing
your knight back on h6 that looks bad queen b6
played there's no easy way to defend this knight
because you don't want to bring your knight back
to e2 like this you can probably get away with it
and actually it's what's played but black instead
of going to h6 going knight back to e5 thanks
to tactics you take my knight oh it's a knife
for a pawn well i'll do the same thing right back
to you i will eventually win your pawn on c6 and
you see the evil voice is zeroes because of course
it's always zeros and chess that's actually really
cool it feels like white has played very natural
moves but still now the evil bar is not really
it's not really thinking that that white is as as
has the great position that they said that they
that they had before so it's really interesting
how how hannah played this i think yes very
like active chess right just throwing the pieces
forward playing c5 which all right the engine
says not the best she'll review the game after and
figure out where she could have improved but this
was a very enterprising style and now after 95 one
more move i take this pawn and as we're discussing
you take i take bishops love open space and this
king on g1 could find itself in trouble especially
if this pawn is taken and the bishop gets to b7
that's a very long diagonal to work with so let's
go to board four we have been here for a while ina
agressed with the white pieces she drew that game
with black in game one where she actually had the
upper hand at the end of the game but time trouble
would not allow her to play for the win at that
moment she felt like she needed to just hold
but we talked about this in a different game anna
are we just gonna see a g4 and a quick attack i
think so i think we're gonna see a g4 um yeah i
i definitely think so i think that that's just
kind of how you want to continue the attack um to
start pushing those pawns i mean i don't really
know if you want to go for instance if you would
like to keep your pawn in g2 to at some point go
e5 and have that g2 pawn defending f3 um i'm
thinking e5 to open up the light square bishop
but yeah in general i think that that's the sort
of ideas we're going to be seeing but instead
inna went for bishop e3 in this position to to
kick the queen away i think she doesn't want
to concern herself with a5 and now the queen and
bishop line up on the b5 pawn so a5 not possible
she's playing maybe a bit reserved at the moment
her pieces are still better but if you're not
careful and you just say oh i'm solid i don't need
to do anything black plays d5 so it's opening up
the board for her pieces and then black could
try to take advantage of it so i think that
bishop d2 okay i see the point don't play rook d8
you'd lose the rook thanks to bishop a5 knight a5
is another thing to consider i i like this it
may be quieter than i would have played had i
had the white pieces going for g4 but she's not
committing herself to anything and if d5 now
she could play e5 you mentioned this idea this
would be a dream come true for the bishop on d3
yep absolutely a bishop on d3 is not really doing
a lot right now of course it's defending c2 but
it's uh it's almost like a big pawn that's
typically what you say when when there's a pawn
right in front of the bishop it sort of becomes
like a pawn itself so to give that bishop some
life that would that would be a dream come true
but i kind of like the fact that she's trying to
position her pieces in in a good way and she's not
really making any big decisions with her pawns yet
and e5 plates is to emphasize what ana just said
that bishop on d3 is not going anywhere and you
could still play g4 this might be the moment to do
so another idea is say rook c1 and c4 because your
king is actually quite safe on b1 and you can
improve your bishop and also open up the queen
side but you're looking at d5 as well that's kind
of a scary move to see so g4 either taking on h5
or pushing through the g5 and there it is you know
plays it she times it well her advantage is still
there according to the engine but i think both
players recognizing it's not you're not thinking
in terms of numbers you think well is this king
going to be safe because the answer is no what
will just win the game and if black can find
out a way to just keep safe for the time being
maybe she'll be able to counter on the queen seven
anna i'm looking at the game between georg and jan
that one's really deep into the end game where
yon just played the move rook lift rook a4 and on
one hand this pawn a5 could be seen as a weakness
if in a king and pawn end game you can go win it
but for now it could be seen as a strength because
maybe rook before rook b6 and use that pawn to
help plant the rook on b6 exactly yeah and if that
pawn is not lost then that pawn is also that one
single pawn on a5 could be stop is stopping the
movement of both the b7 pawn and the a6 pawn so
that one pawn is controlling those two pawns so in
general as long as that pawn is not lost it is a
it is a very strong pawn and if you can reinforce
that pawn with b4 for instance i think that that's
that's definitely that's definitely a a good
pawn so yeah look at the knights here the 96
is actually a good defender the knight on e4 is an
aggressor and white's pawns are kind of perfectly
placed the c3 pawn takes away d4 the g3 pawn takes
away f f4 the h4 pawn takes away g5 the knight has
nowhere to improve at least not from this position
whereas the knight e4 maybe doesn't have anywhere
to improve to but it looks strong here in the
center definitely and if that knight on e6 ever
moves there's gonna be a knight c5 coming in and
that could perhaps be very strong as well but
now instead ian is going for rick before to put
some pressure on b7 and just like you said perhaps
he wants to put his k his work on b6 and because
there the rick would be would be very strong and
would also be putting pressure onto b7 i think
york has to get passive now you don't want to it's
an end game you just can't afford to drop pawns or
allow this knight to infiltrate more you mentioned
the c5 square i would love to get there but knight
d8 maybe you just have to say i don't like it
but i'll go d8 maybe king to c7 or c8 defend this
pawn and king c7 rook to b6 i'm already attacking
your knight so you have to move regardless and
then i probably will end up on this d8 square
sorry doesn't look fun i don't like it
it's defensive and white is taking control
over most of the action but i think york has to
do it has to quickly look at the time he's two
minutes and 40 seconds to yawns five minutes and
40 seconds the thing is that it's always easier
to attack than to defend i think and that can also
be seen in the time control in in the time that if
you are defending it's it's not as fun and you're
probably gonna perhaps think a little bit more if
you're attacking the new the moves just come
very natural to you well speaking of attacking
defending i need to switch games right now because
i just saw the move played here between henry
kleck and maxine lavrov then move with knight e6
and that knight gets up in there hitting the rook
the pawn can't take on e6 because the rook and
f8 is hanging and you're also hitting the pawn
f7 three times all of your firepower aimed towards
that black king and rook e4 played tricky move but
uh there's got to be a mate probably just rook
takes up seven right trying to go over cafe it's
there's nothing you can do about it it's just
checkmate there i played and no matter what you
do you can move the rook anywhere if you take on
f7 the queen replaces the rook and then goes to f8
you're getting checked made out of fate
you see mate in two moves on softball
unstoppable absolutely unstoppable and this
happened so quickly i mean in this position
black was the one we mentioned this idea that
looks really good and then queen h6 all right oh
the rook's e7 rook c4 rook f1 and just not sensing
the danger of this knight coming here and play
bishop c6 maybe bishop c8 is necessarily something
like that but knight e6 that's a winning position
now for white and for team spare what a nice
move that 96 it's just one of those tactics that
if you haven't seen it it really just completely
surprises you because you really were not
expecting that in that position that was a very
very nice find by maxine labroff agreed and let's
go well this game is about to end we'll if the
conclude soon we'll show the final position the
game's lena kashlinskaya and alexander kadatsky
you said attacking is easier than defending how
about this there's a knight on f5 white is down a
piece it was a sacrifice to get here just a couple
moves ago queen e7 knight takes h5 pawn takes
knight f5 you tell us about the garry kasparov
quote right knight's in f5 it's like almost a win
guaranteed and that knight can't be kicked out
h5 is under attack h6 e7 d6 where does this queen
even go f8 that's that feels like a sad move to
play it's not where it wants to be and after queen
takes h5 there's some extra pressure being put on
that bishop and i think that now it's time for the
rook lift the famous work-lift rook for rook d4
oh yes because you can even take on e5 bring your
rook to this is just powering through crushing
and looks like elena kashlinsky the free agent
for gronka bank this is a winning position she
knows it i'm sure that cadetsky knows it well
he's hoping that somehow he can weasel his way
out of this it just then i can't move the knight
moves the bishop is hanging there's a knight in f5
yeah no and this is brilliant rook f4 there we
have it you called for it the players said i
simply must and this is happening before you know
it this king has nowhere to go yeah now this is
uh this seems to just be completely crushing very
very very nice game by alina here instructive play
and rookie you can even take on d6 i probably
would not take that pawn doesn't feel necessary
rook g4 we've been mentioning this idea
oh wait you take the knight but then i
can take on g7 and your queen is trapped so the
best you can do is give up that queen for the
bishop and this knight on g4 is also under
attack your king is going to remain unsafe
and you see the eval bar completely winning
for white so i'm just gonna corner my eye look
at the other two games it looks like the the
end game still going on between georg and yan
the game between ina agrest still plenty of
life in that so i'll let's see if uh alina can
land the knockout that's what i want
to see is she going to play rook to g4
is she just going to take on d6 now the rook
moved out the way what do you think she does
taking on d6 seems kind of good because obviously
it's a pawn and you activate uh you're activating
another piece you're activating your your other
work but i also feel like yeah she's going for
rook g4 i just felt like that pawn on d6 was
really stopping the queen from having any movement
so it's very pretty that after knight takes g4
there's bishop takes g7 and the queen is trapped
yes and you make a good point about you
know the pawn is free you bring a piece in
but you also give black a little bit of time
whereas rook g4 is forcing you're threatening
rook takes g7 your knight is helping out this
knight in f5 it's too strong and knight g6
does not help you because bishop takes g7 still
traps that queen so white is going to win here
very nice alina will even up the match because
spare won with maxine lavrov and let's go to
another game because we know the results that's
going to happen here let's go to ina agrest
game we haven't checked in around against maria
comey and gina where it says zeros every time
we tune into a position it says zeros we're
like wait why is this completely equal it's not
there's plenty of life left even on the clock
though both players at a minute 50 about would you
take white or black ignoring the the evaluation
bar for a second that is a very good question um
i kind of like that black has the idea of going a5
a4 and that they can push that a pawn i feel like
white's attack on the king's side has sort of
stagnated here and it has sort of stopped so
and in that regard i like it i'm not really
sure where this bishop is going to go now
that's what i'm trying to to figure out oh that's
uh important i would play rook d5 because you give
yourself the c5 square and you want to play rook
d5 regardless you think i can't do it i'll lose
my bishop but the rook d5 move would have saved it
although now that might be a pawn worth capturing
that's yup there's a chromosome before that e4
pawn seems to be a strong a very important pawn in
this game also because that e5 pawn it's going to
be could become a very very very strong past pawn
in the end game although free pawns can be
deceiving you take the pawn and then you allow
these rooks to come in and then attack your pawn
the e5 pawn is more important to the defense of
black's king and we did see a victory by elena
kashlinska no surprise there she had won her
opponent's queen and in this game rookie 2 played
i feel like white has a clear plan now so even
though you're down material at least your next
few moves your next idea is more obvious and queen
g4 played don't take on e5 you drop a rook here
can you just play rookie one and try to pile up
yep and i mean that if i pawn okay they're going
rick d2 instead so they're not really going for
the e5 pawn instead of trying to double up on
the default um bishop f fade that's a good move
that's a really good move trying to play bishop
g7 you can't play e4 if the bishop comes in d4
and the queen comes f6 you get checkmated but
if your bishop comes to g7 that helps your king
preemptively yep no i really like that meme
as well queen e6 now the queen is leaving g4
do you think that yeah i don't yeah you shouldn't
really go e4 just yet right e4 is too early here
i wouldn't rush that move and we're gonna just go
between both games there's only two games left and
decides who is the fiji world corporate champion
actually the other game just finishing the draw is
about to bring us they'll show the board really
quickly that game finished as a draw so george
meyer putting up amazing defense his position did
look worse but his rook got very active and just
went around and they repeated moves here uh they
agreed to a draw but you see the engine evaluation
zero black can't move this knight or this king the
b7 pawn and all of white's pawns are defended for
now so a draw was agreed let's go back to the only
game remaining and it is an even match so let's
switch here this game all the marbles black has
25 seconds of counting down but an extra pawn
i would rather have the time oh no rook d a
check queen of fame just changed everything
she found it she finds it and inna agress is about
to win grenkey the world corporate championship
this king is hunted down i've had the feeling
that taking on e4 would give white easier play
and look at that queen f8 threatens mate threatens
mate threatens mate on g8 as well you cannot stop
all three checkmates you don't have a single check
for the black pieces that's made by force wow once
again what a way to finish a game we were saying
that you know this is going to be a long game
where black would have to try to to to convert
this into a win being upon up but this just ended
immediately after this one move which was not
you know super super easy to see immediately but
there's just this checkmate and one of the players
look at them they're so happy they're smiling
they're all really good friends and alina they're
smiling joining them as the free agent that's a
wonderful achievement because they had their backs
against the wall it was 2-2 after the first match
in this match georg was being pressured by yon
napomishi you see them talking they're of course
in a zoom call these were fair play measures
to make sure that the arbiters could see all
the players see their screens and everything to
uphold fair play but look at them it's what i
love to see it's just pure joy they just played
an epic final match and they're look at them all
across those four faces just smiles all around
it's just absolutely amazing to see that and i
think especially the feeling when you're playing
in a team it's just even more amazing to win
because it's not just you but you can share
the happiness about winning with other people
and the people that you're working with here it's
just absolutely amazing to see them all so happy
wow i mean seriously gran ki in general they are
a company that supports chess now their company
that wins world championship titles great to
see that and remind everybody that they're the
champion they have won the world corporate chess
championship and we know the first four teams
they secure seats to participate in online simul
against the winner of the candidates i don't think
the winner of the candidates will be very happy
to face these four players just gonna put like
is jan de palmashi if he wins the candidate
does he play himself in the in the silence
what kind of agreement is this i feel bad
for the win the cans maybe the players
don't want to win the candidates anymore you want
to play magnus for the world championship but
how can you play these people in the symbol
that is that's impossible that's just
that is just cruel frankly and so they get the
title and you see that uh the team that raised the
most money for charity throughout the competition
is invited to the world championship so it's
really great to see this uh tournament come to a
conclusion it was a big fight we saw the smiles
they were ecstatic as granka bank beats spare they
won one and a half half in terms of the individual
matches but it was about the board points they
went four and a half three now that final game
in agres turning around she delivers
a victory when her team needed it
anna that was just awesome that was awesome these
games were so incredibly exciting and just like
you mentioned before it's not just about you
know board number one but it's about all the
other boards and here we can see that inaugures
really really brought the win to to the team
here at the end which was just absolutely amazing
these games i mean they could not have been more
exciting we've seen so many tactics we've seen
so many beautiful beautiful games and all of them
had have ended very quickly after after some nice
tactical variation so it's been an absolute honor
to be able to commentate this with you robert
and just like always and yeah i really hope
that this is not the last the last feed online
world corporate chess championship that they do
i don't think it will be it was a tremendous
success and granted bank we saw them smiling
they clearly have good team chemistry and for that
team just seriously great stuff grenkey you'll
recognize that name not just as world champions in
the fide online world corporate chess championship
but also as sponsors of the grand cake classic
which features the likes of magnus carlsen
and fabiano caruana and some of the top german
players they are represented in the bundesliga
as well so i mean this is just great stuff and
you know people have been asking throughout
the tournament and uh oh is it just bringing
grand masters on teams that doesn't seem right
no the grand master works at grand cay georg meyer
the top board for this team he works at granca so
did two of the other very strong players it
was just alina kashlinska that brought on
that worked to their advantage she's the free
agent she's under that 2500 threshold you could
have only one player above she won the final game
we saw that attack with the knight and f5 so anna
clearly good team chemistry good
choices on whom to bring on to the squad
can't congratulate them enough no absolutely
big big big congrats er to grinky bank for this
absolutely amazing and just to see that
chemistry at the end to see everybody smiling
and being so happy it was a beautiful moment
so can't congratulate them enough either
i'm happy for them i i just was not rooting
for either team but you saw their they're
just joy and that's always good to see you
feels bad for spare they had a great showing
jana palm she led the way and i guess that
half point that he at the end where he let
gary meyer off the hook not that he was ever
winning but he was just applying the pressure
couldn't quite make the breakthrough bjorg is
a very good defender and there is pressure on
players when you're that highly rated to win every
single game i think jan can hold his head high the
whole team can because they just met their match
in grand cay so through and through that spare
team they beat a very strong spare bank trade
union in the semi-finals led by anton korbov
i think that there could only be one champion
but both teams looked equally deserving
gronky gets on top anna it's been a lot of
fun covering the final with you that was
exciting we saw some scrambles we saw a checkmate
in the first set of quarterfinal matches we had a
blitz tie break we it came down to the very last
game it can't get better than that you can't get
better than that i completely agree with you it
was so close all the time there weren't really any
you know big big big 40s or stuff like that
everything was super close all the time and
yeah i mean super exciting match and the fact that
it it was all down to the very last match just
made it even better we've been we've been so so so
me and robert we've been so excited every single
match and we've been having to recover during the
breaks just because the match has been so exciting
so we couldn't have asked for anything else
that's right and before we leave i would be
remiss not to thank fide for organizing this
event for chess.com for being a partner and
putting on the event hosting all the games all
the arbiters who worked tirelessly to make sure
that fair play standards were upheld to make
sure the event ran as smoothly as possible the
rounds beginning on time to everyone behind the
scenes putting in these late hours the nighttime
matchups ended past midnight for plenty
of people or early started early in the
morning if you're in europe so we know that
our producer up early working hard behind
the scenes everyone who's watching we appreciate
you the viewership for chess is a sight to behold
it's great to see the numbers increase as more
people get involved and finally to the players
this event was not possible without them cranky
bank the champions but so many teams deserve our
praise and applause and anna again i really
appreciate you joining me and everybody who
was able to donate thank you so much for your
generosity for helping these initiatives for
feed a for players with disabilities for veteran
players and for education chess on that note
it's time to sign off anna again appreciate
you we'll be commenting again soon i'm sure
and it was an absolute blast yeah definitely
definitely thank you once again for everybody
who organized this event and everybody behind the
scenes and everybody watching all the players it's
uh it's it's been an honor to be able to be here
the very last day and to commentate with you the
finals and yeah i'm sure i'm sure they'll be
commentating more stuff in the future robert
uh maybe even another corporate championship
but for now this one's in the books it is the
first one gregor bank the champions everybody
enjoy the rest of day keep having fun with chess